Wir wollen zurückblicken auf die Saison in der Liga, in La Liga und in der Serie A. Jetzt hier in der Ligatur. Alex Troika ist hier, Christian Bernhardt ist hier und Alexi Menüche ist hier. Wir alle freuen uns schon sehr.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Die Liga Tour ist zurück. Alex Treuker ist hier. Servus Alex, schön, dass du da bist. Servus, Grüße. Christian Bernhard ist hier. Hallo Christian.
Hallihallo.
Sitz wie immer neben mir. Und welch Freude. Alexi Menü hat's wieder geschafft. Hallo Alexi, schön, dass du da bist. Wir mussten schon hart aufpassen, jetzt nicht eine Stunde über die Europameisterschaft zu reden. Ich sag's ganz ehrlich, das hat fast ein bisschen wehgetan, die Diskussion abzuwirken. Aber wir wollen noch mal auf die Ligen zurückblicken. Bevor die Frage kommt, es sieht so aus, als ob wir Premier League nicht noch mit dazu bekommen würden. Es tut mir sehr leid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich weiß, da hätte es einiges zu besprechen gegeben, Klopp, Abschied und so weiter und so fort. Und diese völlig überraschende City-Meisterschaft vor allem. Natürlich. Aber ihr werdet ja auch alle sehen, was sowohl im Rasenfunk als auch anderswo los ist. Es sind einfach sehr viele Termine gerade. Und dann geht das leider unter. Aber es gibt ja hervorragende Premier League-Podcasts, unter anderem diesen Click and Rush, der soll ganz gut sein. Das sind diese Hebel-Brüder. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr von denen schon mal gehört habt. Also da könnt ihr bestimmt einiges zur Premier League hören. Wir machen das heute ein bisschen Freestyle. Wir wollen diesmal nicht so streng nach einem Korsett durchgehen, wie in der letzten Saison, sondern einfach so die wichtigen Geschichten erzählen, die passiert sind in der Liga. Und weil wir die Liga jetzt wirklich so lange nicht mehr dabei hatten, Alexi, dass du gerne mal beginnen. Was war denn für dich jetzt rückblickend eine der wichtigsten überraschendsten, schönsten Geschichten dieser Liga-Saison?
Es sind voll im Zweifel und das betrifft einfach zwei Mannschaften, nicht unbedingt zwei Spieler. Die erste Mannschaft ist nicht PSG, sondern stattbreist der sensationell dritte, mit dem zweitkleinsten Budget der Liga 1 die Saison gestartet. Und eine Mannschaft, die für viele als Abschlusskandidat Nummer eins galt, am Saisonstart. Und im September, Oktober, November, da Manchester, Mailand, München rumfliegen wird. Das ist schon unglaublich. Die haben nicht mal einen eigenen Stand mit der Champions League, weil er nicht oeferkomfort ist und also zum Nachbar Gandon weichen muss. Aber diese Mannschaft hat einfach heraushakt und auch diesen dritten Platz am Ende völlig verdient gehabt, weil die Mannschaft, die eigentlich lange Zeit für defensive Kunst bekannt war, wenig zugelassen hat, aber nach vorne wenig gelang und in dieser Saison haben wir einfach den nächsten State gesehen. Wenn man die fünf spektakulären Liga-Anspiele der Saison zusammenrechnet, dann ist Preis drei oder viermal dabei. Es gab ein 3 zu 4 in Dium und zweimal ein 5 zu 4 in Rennes, also bei einem großen Nachbar. Es wäre, wenn, das ist nicht gut zu überlegen, jetzt haben wir keine zweiten bayerischen Vereine mehr in der Liga, aber wenn Malou Moutarhahim schon fast bei den Bayern mit 5-4 gewinnt, nachdem man 2 zu 4 lange zurück lag. Und noch eine schöne Geschichte bei Stadte Brest, ist der Trainer, Erich Rohr, der ja 11 Jahre lang arbeitslos war. Nach 11 Jahren, sagt man, der hat danach keine Chance, doch irgendwo wieder einzusteigen. Aber der hat seine Chance genutzt, ist jetzt eineinhalb Jahre im Amt und wie gesagt führt Stadte Brest zur ersten Champions League-Teilnahme. Das ist schon eine Kunst und für mich und auch für Philipp Franka natürlich Sensation der Saison ist Stadte Brest.
Aber weil du gesagt hast, zweitkleinster Etat der Liga, was heißt denn zweitkleinster? Also kann man da so grob eine Hausnummer nennen? Für die Personaletat? Okay, gut, PSG ist dann natürlich der Outlier. Also hier ist jetzt mal der Bundesliga-Vergleich wirklich angebracht. Ansonsten breche ich ihn ja manchmal etwas übers Knie. Ich gebe es ja zu. Also schauen wir doch mal, was es sonst so für einen Personalauffwand gibt. Also 47 Millionen hat der FC Augsburg zum Beispiel gehabt vor drei Jahren. 80 Millionen härter BSC. Sehe ich hier gerade. Union, das ist vielleicht dann ein ganz guter Vergleich. Auch 37, 40 Millionen, wobei die jetzt zum letzten Jahr schon gestiegen sein sollten. Lass mal bei Eric Waab bleiben. Ich habe kurz schon überlegt, ob das der französische Tim Funkel ist, aber da hört es dann schon auf, weil der war ja nicht so lange da.
Kleine Junge.
Ja, ja, Alex leidet schon wieder. Aber da war ja vorher Sportdirektor in Wartford und der hatte sich ja quasi von dieser Trainertätigkeit eigentlich verabschiedet. Wie ist es überhaupt gekommen, dass er jetzt wieder an der Seitenlinie gestanden ist bei Brest?
Der Sportdirektor war ja auch in Nizza mal kurz und dann in Wartford, war aber auch Fernseh-Experte und viele Kollegen haben erzählt, dass er schon das Kribbeln hat, dass er schon wieder Trainer werden möchte. Und er wuchte natürlich nicht, wenn elf Jahre lang, also es war nicht so, dass elf Jahre lang kein Angebot auf seinem Schreibtisch kam, aber er hatte trotzdem keinen Job und in elf Jahren entwickelt sich auch die Fußballbranche, sind eine Spielergeneration und wie gehst du mit dieser neuen Herausforderung um? Aber er hat es nie komplett aufgegeben und Kollegen haben behauptet, so drei, vier Monate bevor Brest ihn kontaktiert hat, vor eineinhalb Jahren, es war schon genau der Zeitpunkt, wo er wieder einsteigen wollte. Und das kam, wie gesagt, wirklich zum besten Zeitpunkt und dann hat er natürlich die nötige Zeit, sich vorzubereiten auf diese neue Aufgabe, weil hätte er gescheitert, wäre es wahrscheinlich seine letzte Station gewesen, zumindest in der ersten Liga. Und jetzt macht er sich auf sich aufmerksam. Er hat sicherlich schon jetzt lukrativere Angebote bekommen in den letzten Tagen und Wochen, auch wenn er in der kommenden Spielzeit in Brest bleib wird. Und auch interessant, er war damals zusammen mit Zinedine Zidane, der leider nicht Bayern-Trainer wurde übrigens, Max, dazu Willy Sainiol und noch einer, zu Gast bei Pierre Guardiola, bei einem Trainerlehrer an der Säbener Straße 2015, Rigoure. Und das zeigt, dass er schon immer wieder versucht, da in die Fußstrapfen der Größten zu kommen. Und er hat schon was drauf, also er hat eine starke Persönlichkeit, bestellt aber die Jugendspieler auch, obwohl er wirklich älter ist. Und man merkt, es war sein Ehrgeiz, sein Fleiß jeden Tag. Und jetzt wird er gefeiert, aber er bleibt relativ bescheiden. Und ich kann mich erinnern, dass er als Spieler, weil er auch ein großer Spieler, relativ arrogant wirkte, aber vielleicht haben ihn diese 11 Jahre Arbeitslosigkeit ein bisschen auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückgebracht.
Wobei ich nach dem, was du gesagt hast, das Wort Arbeitslosigkeit absprechen würde, wenn er TV-Experte war und so weiter und so fort. Also in dem Sinne wäre ja Lothar Matthäus auch arbeitslos. Weil er ja leider nur auf allen Sendern dieser Welt jedes Fußball spielt. Ja genau, und Zeitungen und alles. Aber wenn ich mir jetzt die Transfers angucke von Press. Also zum einen haben wir natürlich diese Franck-Honorat-Geschichte. Das war der große Abgang im Sommer, der wahrscheinlich auch noch mal anders auf diese Champions-League-Qualifikation blickt, weil er gleichzeitig in Gladbach sitzt und gegen den Abstieg spielen musste. Aber er wurde ja nicht irgendwie teuer nachverpflichtet. Wer macht denn die Transfers bei Press? Ist das dann in seiner Sportdirektoren-Erfahrung jemand anders? Hatten die jetzt einfach Glück, dass man das so auffangen konnte?
Auch eine neue Tensation auf diesem Posten, weil er nicht so bekannt war. Aber bei fast jedem Transfer hat er recht behalten. Hat sehr viel Delegenz gezeigt. Natürlich hat ihm Gregorio dabei geholfen. Aber Lorenzi ist schon länger im Amt in Bres. Der war jetzt auch kurz vor dem Wechsel zum großen Nachbarn aus Rennes. Hat aber doch abgesagt und soll auch in Bres der Saison hinausbleiben. Aber er ist schon der große Macher dieses Aufstiegs von Bres, Gregorio Lorenzi.
Sehr gut, den Namen merken wir uns doch auf jeden Fall auch mal. Also Bres ist wirklich eine schöne Geschichte, vor allem auch mit spektrekulären Spielen. Haben die nicht sogar auch gegen Monaco mal so hoch gewonnen diese Saison? Also irgendwann hatten wir das auf jeden Fall. Wir hatten es ja auf jeden Fall schon mehrfach hier in der Sendung. Schön, die jetzt dann in der Champions League zu sehen. Über den Topf müssen wir nicht diskutieren, indem sie landen werden. Mit dem VfB Stuttgart, sag ich mal. Genau, das wird es halt wirklich sein. Ja schön, Stadt-Brest, eine der schönen Geschichten dieser Saison im europäischen Fußball. Was haben wir denn da in der Serie A? Christian, was wäre da für dich eine schöne Geschichte?
Da gibt es viele, aber ich würde jetzt mit Atalanta und Gasperini anfangen. Da kommt ja auch kompletter europäischer Charakter mit rein. Also ja, haben wir diese Saison ja auch schon ein, zwei Mal drüber gesprochen, aber das jetzt Atalanta gerade eben mit diesem am Ende, also ich würde sagen, das war wirklich mal eine Kirsche auf die Torte, dieses Europa League-Finale, nicht nur, dass sie es geholt haben, sondern die Art und Weise, also dass Atalanta und Gasperini jetzt wirklich den Weg gekrönt haben, finde ich herausragend. Ich darf nicht vergessen, Gasperini, das war seine achte Saison bei Atalanta. Was da schon alles passiert ist, er hat selbst auch in der Saison gesprochen, das war jetzt so mein Atalanta 3, also die Version 3.0 sozusagen. Viele erinnern sich vielleicht noch vor ein paar Jahren an diese legendäre Papu Gomes, Ilicic Atalanta Mannschaft, die dann ja schon in der Champions League für Furore gesorgt hat. Und die diesjährige Mannschaft, Gasperini hat das immer auch sehr schön beschrieben, hat gemeint, wir hatten vielleicht nicht so viel Talent wie diese Version, eben gerade mit Ilicic und Gomes, aber dieses Zusammenführen von Körperathletik, also nochmal ein ganz anderes athletisches Niveau, also für mich sind so die Sinsspieler, das sind Coop Miners und Ederson, wenn du die zwei hernimmst, das ist Gasperini sozusagen. Und dazu dann jetzt diese neue defensive Stabilität, die sie reingebracht haben. Und trotzdem aber ja dieses mutige Offensiv, ja Offensive vielleicht jetzt nicht auf dem Papier quasi, also diese Ilicic, Papu Gomes, die war glaube ich ein bisschen wilder, da gab es ja auch oft diese 4-3 Spiele und so, da sind sie jetzt kontrollierter geworden. Aber ja, wie gesagt, allein dieses Finale gegen Leverkusen, ich finde ja am Ende, finde ich, bei einem Finale, im Finale musst du halt gewinnen. Wie du das gewinnst, ist dann ja manchmal auch relativ egal.
Der Real-Fan.
Genau, da kommen wir später nochmal dazu. Aber eine Mannschaft, die, was waren es, 52 Spiele glaube ich bei Leverkusen, oder? Die 52 Spiele ungeschlagen war und dann in einem Finale, die so zu dominieren. Mir ist danach so gekommen, ich hatte so das Gefühl, Leverkusen wurde mal so richtig atalantisiert in dem Spiel. Also da ist wirklich alles zusammengekommen, was den Gasparini-Style ausmacht quasi. Und es ist ja eben viel mehr als nur dieses eine Spiel. Also es ist jetzt ein Aufhänger, wenn wir uns gerade in den europäischen Weg anschauen von Atalanta. Ich meine, die gewinnen an der Anfield Road bei Liverpool mit 3 zu 0 und das noch in einer Phase, in der Liverpool noch voll im Meisterrennen war. Also es war ja noch, bevor es dann bei Liverpool ein bisschen abgeklungen ist. Dazu Sporting Lissabon, die haben den portugiesischen Meister sowohl in der Gruppenphase als auch in der KU-Phase noch mal rausgenommen. Und das 3-0 gegen Marseille auch im Halbfinale-Rückspiel. Also allein 3-0 an der Anfield Road gewinnen, 3-0 gegen Marseille und dann 3-0 Leverkusen. Ja, herausragend. Und dazu halt eben auch in der Liga. Sie haben es ja dann in der Liga, hätten sie es ja auch in die Champions League geschafft quasi. Sie sind am Ende eben Vierter geworden. Im Frühling sind sie in diesen Atalanta-Modus reingekommen. Diese Athletik, diese Intensität, die Gasperini fordert. Schön auch jetzt seit dem Titel wirklich ein Riesenfest in Bergamo. Sie sind auch mit dem offenen Bus durch die Stadt gefahren. Da wird im Prinzip seitdem gefeiert. Und Gasperini hat es auch immer wieder gesagt. Deswegen meinte ich eben, Cobmeiners und Ederson sind für mich so ein bisschen die Sinnbilder. Weil diese Athletik, diese Körperlichkeit, diese Intensität und gepaart dann mit diesem Mut, mit diesem nach vorne Verteidigen, den Gegner im Idealfall, wenn es klappt, zu erdrücken. Das war einfach herausragend. Und das Schöne finde ich, Gasperini hat es auch in den Wochen davor schon immer gesagt, klar werden Mannschaften oder auch große Trainer im Prinzip dann immer irgendwann auch an Titeln gemessen. Und deswegen war das jetzt wirklich, glaube ich, auch extrem wichtig, dass diese achtjährige Zeit, in der so viel Schönes und Gutes passiert, dass sie es jetzt wirklich auch Silberware quasi bekommen hat. Aber Gasperini hat es auch in den Wochen davor gesagt, und das unterschreibe ich voll, es sind schon oft die Momente, die bleiben. Und er hat gemeint, egal was da jetzt am Saisonende passiert, wir haben ja auf jeden Fall viele Erinnerungen hinterlassen. Allein ein 3-0 an der Anfield Road zu gewinnen, an einer vollen Anfield Road, denn sie hatten ja schon in der Champions League vor ein paar Jahren an der Anfield Road gewonnen, aber das war zu Corona-Zeiten. Das sind Sachen, die bleiben logisch auch in der Clubgeschichte. Noch einmal zur Erinnerung, Bergamo hat 120.000 Einwohner. Also wir reden da jetzt nicht von einer Metropole quasi. Und ja, deswegen finde ich, gepürt ist, mit Atalanta anzufangen. Klar, auch wenn sie nicht jetzt die Meisterschaft geholt haben, aber nicht vergessen, sie waren ja auch im Coppa Italia-Finale. Also sie sind überall den Weg gegangen. Sie haben in der Liga das geschafft, was sie wollten, nämlich die Champions League-Quali einzutüten. Sie hätten es dann jetzt ja eh auch über den Europa League-Sieg doppelt gemacht. Sie haben auch ein paar Spieler auf ein neues Niveau gehoben. Ederson auf ein neues Niveau gehoben. De Ketellare ist eigentlich das beste Beispiel. Der junge Mann, der bei Milan letztes Jahr wie verloren wirkte, dem das irgendwie alles zu groß schien, da er diesen krassen Rucksack an Druck mitgetragen hat. Dann kommt er nach Bergamo und dann passiert genau das, was alle halt auch hofften. Denn jeder wusste, De Ketellare kann was. Es war nicht ein Thema, dass er nichts kann. Dann ist er genau an den richtigen Punkt gekommen. Um jetzt auch bei Gasperini nochmal den Kreis zu schließen. Gasperini hat jetzt über Jahre sehr viele Spieler auf ein neues Niveau gehoben. Wenn ich mir Coop Miners anschaue, was der jetzt nochmal für einen Schritt gemacht hat, wenn man sich Ederson anschaut, wenn man sich Skamaka anschaut, der ja auch so ein bisschen lost war, nach England ist, bei Westheim nicht wirklich funktioniert. Viele Angebote auf dem Tisch hatte, der hätte auch zu Inter gehen können, der hat zu Europa gehen können, aber er sagt, nein, ich wollte nach Bergamo, weil ich wollte zu Gasperini. Und jetzt mal schauen, was Gasperini auch aus Skamaka gemacht hat. Also wirklich, ich finde, nicht nur eine Geschichte dieser Saison, sondern in dem Fall eben, weil es 8 Jahre sind, wirklich eine Geschichte, die sich lange angedeutet hat und die jetzt einfach einen ganz besonderen Moment gefunden hat.
Da konntest du auch quasi diejenigen unterscheiden, von denen, die nicht so tief drin sind, die, die sich mit Gasperini, mitgefreund haben, die so ein bisschen was von dieser Geschichte kannten. Das war klar zu erkennen, wer sich quasi schon vor dem Europa League-Finale mit Atalanta beschäftigt hat. Würdest du sagen, Atalanta ist die fitteste Mannschaft der Serie A?
Ja, zusammen mit Inter auf jeden Fall. Für mich waren es schon die letzten Jahre, das waren schon so zwei, drei Jahre. Atalanta hat immer diesen europäischen Style-Song gehabt, weil sie den Rhythmus auch, wie gesagt, auch gegen Premier League-Mannschaften, sie gehen den Rhythmus einfach mit. Das ist überhaupt kein Thema. Man dürfte zum Beispiel nicht vergessen, ich habe es mir extra nochmal angeschaut, seit Ende Februar hatten die nur englische Wochen. Weil ja auch in Italien ist ja Coppa Italia, Halbfinale ist Hin und Drückspiel, dann eben der ganze europäische Weg, dann gab es ja ein paar englische Wochen auch in der Liga. Und du hast eher das Gefühl, je mehr die spielen, desto fitter werden die. Das ist schon die Grundlage dieses schau dir Coop Miners an, da wird marschiert, da werden Meter gemacht. Das ist die Grundlage, deswegen als Spieler bei Atalanta, wenn du dich in die Hände von Gasperini gibst, das ist schon ein heftiges Programm. Das erzählen auch viele Spieler. Die Trainingseinheiten erzählen viele, die nach Bergamo kommen, sagen, sie hatten noch nie so intensive. Du musst da schon viel dalassen, aber wenn du bereit bist, das zu geben, dann macht dich Gasperini, also dich individuell und die ganze Mannschaft bringt dich auf das nächste Niveau sozusagen. Das ist jetzt nicht die klassische Wohlfühloase im Sinne von, das ist alles tralala und schön gemütlich, sondern du musst da schon wahnsinnig viel investieren. Aber wir hatten es ja auch schon die letzten Jahre in der Serie. Schau dir an, wie viele Spieler... Robin Gosens ist jetzt ja das perfekte Beispiel, auch aus deutscher Sicht. Woher kam Robin Gosens? Was hat Robin Gosens? Logisch eher auch. Ich finde, man muss da schon die Spieler auch immer mit reinnehmen, weil du musst eben auch diese Bereitschaft haben, den Weg zu gehen. Und wohin hat Atalanta und Robin Gosens sich selbst gebracht, auch unter dieser Gasperini-Arbeit. Und deswegen war das jetzt wirklich... Ja, wie gesagt, da haben sich wirklich viele mit gefreut, weil jetzt einfach wirklich der Zeitpunkt war, auch mal was zu ernten sozusagen von dem vielen, was sie gesät haben und von dem vielen, was auch so oder so geblieben wäre, auch wenn die jetzt das Finale gegen Leverkusen verloren hätten. Aber jetzt war halt endlich mal Zeit, das einzufangen. Und ein letzter Gedanke dazu, den fand ich wirklich, es war echt ein besonderer Moment. Atalanta hatte ja die Woche davor, das war genau der Mittwoch davor, das Coppa Italia-Finale. Also dieses Jahr hatten sie ja zwei Finalschancen. Und dann verlieren sie zum dritten Mal unter Gasperini das Coppa Italia-Finale gegen Juve, haben es schon mal gegen Juve verloren, auch schon mal gegen Lazio. Und dann war halt schon so die Frage, uiuiui, wieder dieser Finalfluch, und jetzt eine Woche später gegen die ungeschlagenen Leverkusen, oder so, klappt wohl wieder nicht. Und es gab den Moment nach dem Finale, in Rom ja eben, Juve 1-0 gewonnen, wo Juve wirklich sehr scharf war, wo man gesehen hat, wie du Atalanta halt irgendwie auch begegnen kannst, klar. Und Gasperini war aber im Moment schon nach dem Schlusspfiff und auch schon bei der Medaillenübergabe, er hatte so ein Lächeln im Gesicht. Also in keinster Weise arrogant oder hämisch, sondern der hat da schon, glaube ich, gemerkt, die können das eine Woche später leisten. Und Gasperini hat das auch die ganzen Wochen davor immer wieder gesagt, unser primäres Ziel ist die Europa League, unser primäres Ziel ist die Europa League. Auch wirklich diesen europischen Weg zu krönen. Und dann muss ich sagen, das dann wirklich so durchzuziehen, dann auch auf die Art und Weise Hut ab.
Also zwei Gedanken meinerseits dazu noch. Das eine ist, wir bewegen uns hier im absoluten Top-Niveau des Leistungssports Fußball. Und trotzdem macht es offenbar immer noch einen Unterschied, wie fit manche Mannschaften sind. Also ich verstehe es nicht.
Du meinst, dass das andere nicht auf mir ist.
Also warum kann das noch so einen Unterschied machen? Ich verstehe es in einzelnen Spielen, in Verletzungen und so weiter. Ja, aber insgesamt verstehe ich es eigentlich nicht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Und das zweite ist, dass ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, wer eigentlich in den anderen Ligen, die jetzt hier anwesend sind, die fittesten Teams waren. Alex, was würdest du denn sagen? Wer war das physisch beste Team in der spanischen Liga?
Boah, das ist jetzt eine gute Frage. Ich finde, das ist immer vom Fernseher weg, das einzuschätzen, das ist ein bisschen schwerer. Da müsste man, glaube ich, schon eher im Stadion vor Ort häufiger sein. Auch natürlich bei den verschiedenen Mannschaften auch näher dran. Also nicht 10 Kilometer weit weg im Camp Nou oder Bernabeu, irgendwo oben sitzen, sondern wirklich am Spielfeld dran. Dann wird es mir leichter fallen. Da spreche ich auch als Amateur-Trainer so ein bisschen. Je näher dran du bist, desto eher fühlst du, spürst du, siehst du es. Aber irgendwie muss man leider an Real Madrid denken. Warum sage ich leider? Weil auch wir in Deutschland gepeinigt sind von den vielen, vielen späten Toren, die sie schießen. Und wie kannst du die schießen, wenn du fit bist? Also mental fit, aber natürlich auch körperlich fit. Und das haben sie auch vor zwei Jahren schon gezeigt. Gegen PSG und gegen Man City. Und auch jetzt haben sie es gegen die Bayern gezeigt, dass sie hinten raus wirklich noch Körner haben, noch den Gang oder sogar zwei Gänge hochschalten können. Müssen sie natürlich nicht immer machen in der Liga. Gegen kleinere Vereine reicht es halt oft, ja, nur im vierten Gang zu spielen. Aber sie zeigen halt, dass sie wirklich noch immer hinten raus was drauflegen können. Von daher liegt der Gedanke nahe, dass es vielleicht Real Madrid ist. Auch wenn man es nicht in jedem Spiel sieht, weil es ist, wie gesagt, nicht in jedem Spiel an die Leistung funktioniert.
Aber gegen Bayern, da war der Unterschied sehr deutlich zu sehen. Da waren zwar einige Bayern-Fans sehr sauer auf mich, aber ich bleibe dabei. Für mich sahen die Bayern total platt aus im Halbfinale-Rückspiel. Auch deswegen war Real, glaube ich, mental in der Lage, die Chancen, die da lagen, auch gleich zu nutzen und nicht erst noch in der Verlängerung zu müssen.
Vor der Glotze sitzen wäre das jetzt auch mein Take gewesen. Aber da ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Es ist vielleicht noch mal anders, wenn man näher dran ist. Aber ich habe das gleiche Gefühl wie du, dass die Bayern eher platt sind. Und Real hat wirklich hinten raus noch die Körner. Man hat natürlich auch gut gewechselt, dass du Jose Lu einwechselst und der macht die Flore. Das ist dann weniger Fitness. Aber man hat schon gesehen, Real kann hinten raus wirklich noch was beisteuern. Bei den Bayern wirkt die Mannschaft schon ein bisschen platter.
Und dann ist jetzt die Frage, Alexi, wer sind die Trainingsweltmeister der Liga? Du schwarmst ja geradezu vom Training in der Liga.
Wenn das nicht PSG ist, Alexi. Dabei ist Meymar gar nicht mehr da. Der Trainingsweltmeister. Und der Olympique Lyon, weil Lyon hat sehr oft Spätetore erzielt. Und deshalb der Leverkusen 2022, 2023. Letzter im Herbst und 6. Tabellenende. Also geht davon aus, dass nächste Saison Lyon Meister wird ohne eine einzige Niederlage.
Bei dir weiß man immer nicht, Alexi, ob du das wirklich ernst meinst. Man muss ja auch sagen, jeder, der den Rasenfunk gehört hat, der wusste ja auch, was kommt. Du warst im Januar, glaube ich, zu Gast. Und da hast du gesagt, Lyon, die haben sich jetzt den besten Transfer im Winter gemacht. Die kommen jetzt raus. Und da hast du gesagt, die werden auf jeden Fall europäisch, glaube ich, noch spielen. Also du hast es von allen gesehen. Das heißt, die sind sehr fit. Und Adi Hütter hat auch die Monigassen fit gemacht. Ja, das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Ja, ich meine, es ist eine sehr athletische Mannschaft mit Zakaria, mit Kamara, mit Fofa, mit Mildfeld. Sehr athletisch. Der 2 kam stark. Auch wenn Zakaria sehr oft verletzt ist und undiszipliniert. Aber er hat die Mannschaft richtig viel gemacht. Natürlich war man nicht europäisch vertreten, sodass man nur ein Spiel pro Woche hatte. Aber die Vizemeisterschaft von Adi Hütter war auch damit verbunden.
Dass die Mannschaft am fittesten war mit Orwell. Ich bin völlig bei dir auf dem höchsten Niveau, dass es dann manchmal noch diese Unterschiede gibt. Vor ein paar Spieltagen gab es Atalanta-Roma. Das war kurz vor Ende, wo es auch noch für beide um die Champions-League-Quali ging. Das war drei Tage nachdem beide, die Roma, an Leverkusen gescheitert waren im Halbfinale. Und Atalanta eben dieses 3-0 gegen Marseille hatte. Ich habe das kommentiert und ich muss sagen, es war wirklich in der ersten Hälfte, man hat Mitleid mit der Roma bekommen. Weil die wurden völlig körperlich einfach. Das war logisch eine Kombination aus körperlich und mental, weil die Roma in Leverkusen wahnsinnig viel liegen lassen, hat ja am Ende noch an der Verlängerung geschnuppert. Dann hast du diese negative Erfahrung vom Ausscheiden. Und die Roma hat auch nicht die Kader-Tiefe von Atalanta, konnte das einfach nicht auffangen. Und Atalanta sind über die drüber gerollt. Am Ende war es dann zwar knapp gegen nur 2-1 aus, weil sie wahnsinnig viel liegen haben lassen, aber das war wirklich, wo man sich sagt, wow, das sind jetzt zwei Top-Teams sozusagen. Und die haben mit denen körperlich gemacht, was sie wollten. Und gegen Leverkusen im Prinzip ging es im Finale so weiter. Also die haben die wirklich von Minute 1 aufgefressen, athletisch. Und das ist schon wirklich herausragend. Und einen möchte, also das ist zwar nur das Finale, aber ich fand, alle haben völlig zu Recht über Lückmann geredet, wer im Finale drei Buden macht und was für Buden auch, völlig zu Recht. Aber was Ederson in dem Spiel gespielt hat, also ich habe lange nicht mehr ein Spiel, an so einem wichtigen Spiel, so herausragend gesehen. Also was der abgelaufen ist, du hast echt das Gefühl gehabt, es gab drei Ederson, der war immer da, auf dem Feld, überall. Ich glaube, eine Szene ist mal hängen in der 2. Hälfte, ist er noch mal Frimpong abgelaufen. Frimpong hat noch mal zur Ecke geklärt, auch ohne Faul. Ist jetzt ja auch brasilianischer Nationalspieler geworden. Auch das zeigt eben so ein perfektes Beispiel dafür, dass den Gasperini halt auch noch mal auf ein ganz anderes Niveau gehoben hat. Da könnte man jetzt eine lange Liste fortführen. Deswegen finde ich schon eine der besonderssten Geschichten aus Italien in diesem Jahr.
Aber wirklich. Und dennoch, obwohl ich schon ein Tribümgespräch mit einem Athletiktrainer gemacht habe, so ganz verstehe ich es immer noch nicht, warum das im Fußball, also Belastungssteuerung in ganz vielen anderen Sportarten bedeutet, dass ja innerhalb eines Spiels, macht man man nicht alle Minuten. Oder jetzt auch, wenn gerade Playoffs laufen in NBA und NHL, denke ich mir auch, also es ist erstaunlich. Also Thema physisch im Fußball, ich glaube irgendwie, da steckt noch was Interessantes drin, wo vielleicht auch Verbesserungspotenzial noch kommen wird, in den nächsten Jahren. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal nach Spanien blicken. Alex, welche Geschichte hast du uns da mitgebracht? Die vom völlig unwahrscheinlichen Champions League Sieg von Real oder?
Nee, die möchte ich nicht sprechen, aber die passt ja hier auch nicht rein, denn das war ja die Champions League, das ist ja hier die Ligatur, also der Beruf mit auf die Ligen. Ich will aber noch anknüpfen an die Frage, wer ist die fitteste Mannschaft? Ich muss nämlich auch an den FC Girona denken. Ich glaube nämlich im Nachhinein, das ist die Mannschaft, die die meisten Rückstände gedreht hat. Neben Real Madrid, die ja berühmt berüchtigt dafür sind, aber vor allem natürlich in der Champions League, in der Liga, müssen sie es nicht ganz so häufig tun, weil Girona war das anders. Die haben in der Liga die meisten Rückstände gedreht. Und dann kommt es natürlich automatisch zu der Frage oder zu dem Thema, dann sind sie wohl nicht ganz unfit, wenn sie das können. Von daher würde ich da auch Girona in dieser Kategorie nennen. Aber kleine Asterix, kleiner Stern am Ende, sie haben halt nicht europäisch gespielt. Also wenn die eine Doppelbelastung gehabt hätten, die ganze Saison über, sehe es vielleicht anders aus, können wir ja nächstes Jahr herausfinden. Denn wunderschöne Überleitung, das ist glaube ich auch dann hier, die passend zu euren Teams, die Überraschungsmannschaft oder die Mannschaft, über die man sprechen muss. Denn sie hat auch Historisches geschafft, genauso wie Atalanta, erster Titel, oder erster europäischer Titel, genauso wie Brest erstmals überhaupt in der Champions League. Auch der FC Girona ist das erste Mal in der Vereinsgeschichte europäisch vertreten und dann auch direkt die Champions League-Teilnahme. Also das ist wirklich die Mannschaft der Saison, denke ich, die Story der Saison in Spanien. Platz 3 des FC Girona, der zwischenzeitlich glaube ich sogar im Winter auf Platz 1 stand und nie eingebrochen ist, was man vielleicht irgendwann so ein bisschen erwarten konnte. Nee, die haben durchgezogen und völlig zu Recht in der Champions League.
Waren tatsächlich nur am ersten Spieltag nicht innerhalb der Champions League-Ränge, ansonsten permanent. Und wir haben ja auch immer wieder über Girona schon gesprochen und auch die ganzen Nebengeschichten. Man muss da auch quasi das Steinchen dran machen. Manchester City Filiale letztlich, auch wenn die UEFA das anders sieht, weil es sind ja nicht mehr als 50 Prozent, die der City Holding gehören. Also deswegen weiß ich auch nicht, wo das Problem ist. Aber die UEFA Multi-Club-Honorship haben gar kein Problem mit. Die haben jetzt ja auch mit Manchester United und NHTSA, mit Red Cliff und so weiter hat die UEFA auch schon gesagt, Leute, chillt mal, das ist doch gar kein Problem. Deswegen, das haben wir schon oft genug thematisiert, deswegen müssen wir das jetzt nicht auch noch mal hier im Saisonrückblick machen. Ich sage es nur, weil es könnten ja Nachfragen von Hörern und Törern kommen, die jetzt vielleicht nur diese Sendung sehen. Lass mal aufs Sportliche gucken. Also sie haben viele Rückstände gedreht, 25 Punkte nach Rückständen geholt, das sind mehr als Real 23, mehr als Barca mit 19. Dann übrigens schon Vier Real, das fand ich ganz interessant, hätte ich da nicht so weit oben erwartet und Celta Vico kommt dann schon dahinter. Aber die lagen auch ein bisschen öfter zurück, deswegen war es ein bisschen einfacher, doch diese Punkte zu holen. Aber was würdest du denn sagen, hat Girona sportlich ausgezeichnet in dieser Saison? Was für ein Fußball haben sie gespielt?
Also grundsätzlich muss man natürlich sagen, dass sie Vollgas-Fußball spielen. 85 Saison-Tore, nur zwei weniger als Real Madrid, mit dann doch ein bisschen anderen Spielern in einem anderen Budget. Auch wenn die City Group dahinter steckt. Aber das ist dann wirklich bemerkenswert. Sie haben die meisten Torschancen übrigens, oder Großchancen, herausgespielt in der Liga. 131 Big Chances, Barca 126, Real Madrid 123. Also das zeigt schon auf. Die geben Vollgas, die spielen nach vorne. Sie sind sehr variabel, sind ultra gut im Umschaltspiel, im Konter nach der Balleroberung. Sie können aber auch mit dem Ball das Spiel machen. Sie spielen viel über die Flügel, sind da sehr variabel. Es ist nicht nur so, dass sie Flanken spammen, was du ganz besonders liebst, Max, wie wir alle wissen. Sondern sie sind wirklich ultra unausrechenbar. Sie haben dribbelstarke Flügelspieler, die natürlich auch ins 1 gegen 1 gehen. Savino ist da zu nennen, eine der Entdeckungen der Saison. Du weißt nicht, zieh da rechts vorbei, zieh da links vorbei. Es spielen sehr viele Cutbacks, also diese Rückpässe in den Rückraum. Sie haben da eine gute Strafraumbesetzung. Sie haben vorne in Dovbüg den Torschützenkönig der Saison. Sie sind sehr variabel im Angriff. Sie sind passsicher, sind gut am Ball, können umschalten. Das ist wirklich das Komplettpaket. Mental haben wir auch darüber gesprochen, weil sie sehr viele Rückstände drehen. Sie sind sehr fit, sehr laufstark. Das ist wirklich die Leistung der Saison einer Mannschaft in vielerlei Hinsicht, was Girona dahingelegt hat.
Glaubst du, das kann auch etwas Nachhaltiges sein? Das ist eine Frage, vor der stehen natürlich alle Teams. Brest und Atalanta ist ein anderes Beispiel. Girona hat dann doch eine andere Grundlage, auf der man aufbauen kann, auch wegen der Beteiligung der City Group. Die sind zu großen Teilen sehr jung, die wichtigen Spieler. Dolfbeck ist ja schon in Anführungszeichen 26, muss man sagen. Aber Servindio ist 20 Jahre alt. Von dem könnten wir noch 10 sehr gute Jahre sehen.
Wobei, der gehört ja der City Group. Der muss jetzt zu Man City und dann muss man abwarten, ob er da bleibt. Den haben sie schon zurückgeholt. Er gehört ja, da weiß jetzt Alexi mehr. Ist das so Show, die auch der City Group gehören, Alexi? Okay, dann auf jeden Fall gehört er der Mannschaft der City Group. Also Trois, von Trois wurde er geholt.
Ach, das ist der, der kein Spiel für Trois gemacht hat, weshalb die Bengalos geflogen sind beim Abstieg. Das ist Savinjo. Okay, Kronleuchter gerade aufgegangen.
Sie dürfen natürlich entscheiden, wo sie ihn hinschieben. Und aktuell schieben sie ihn, glaube ich, zum Man City, weil das ja wirklich eine Entdeckung der Saison ist. Aber wer weiß, wo er dann am Ende landet. Das macht es dann natürlich ein bisschen, ja, da ist der Stern ein bisschen größer am Satzende von uns, in der Klammer, bezüglich City Group. Aber klar, wenn du jetzt den verlierst, Dorfbüch wird zum Beispiel jetzt schon, der Tor-Schützenkönig, wie genannt, wird jetzt schon von Athletiker umworben, die ihn da vielleicht loseisen können. Da muss man natürlich auch abwarten, was da verhandelt wird oder ob die City Group da doch irgendwie über den Sponsor Etty hat, der jetzt der neue Hauptsponsor wird, dann doch ein paar Millionen reinschieben.
Das hat mich wirklich umgehauen, dass Etty hat Bock, Tyrone zu sponsoren. Die arbeiten halt einfach gut. Die arbeiten einfach so gut, dass dann Etty hat kommt und sagt, jetzt wollen wir auch bei euch...
Max triggert.
Unglaublich.
Hab ich noch nie erlebt. Früher hättest du gesagt, wenn so ein kleiner Verein da einen Star plötzlich entwickelt und dann kommt ein großer Verein wie Athletico oder wer auch immer und die bieten 30, 40, 50 Millionen, dann ist der sofort weg, der Spieler. Aber ist das der Fall, wenn dahinter die City Group steckt? Das ist schwer zu sagen. Es kann sein, dass es so kommt, aber es kann auch sein, dass man irgendeinen Sponsor findet, der dann doch das auffängt, sodass man nicht an den Verkauf zwingend tätigen muss. Also muss man einfach abwarten. Es hat so ein bisschen Geschmäckler, das ist schon klar. Und ob sie die Mannschaft so zusammenhalten können, muss man jetzt abwarten. Auch weil du gefragt hast, ist es nachhaltig, können sie das reproduzieren, wenn sie in Europa spielen, wenn sie die Doppelbelastung haben, ist es natürlich auch schwer zu prognostizieren. Sie hatten es ja noch nie. Also auch der Coach Michel, für mich der Coach des Jahres, was er da gemacht hat, hat auch noch nie europäisch trainiert. Der war nur bei Rayo Valle Cano und bei Huesca als Trainer. Ist mit Huesca dann auch entlassen worden, weil sie im Abstiegskampf steckte. Also kommt ja aus ganz anderen Gefilden, hat eben auch noch nie. Du bist ja immer wieder bei Trainingsbelastung, Trainingssteuerung, das musste er auch erst mal implementieren. In seinem Training musste er bisher nicht, weil er noch nie europäisch gespielt hat. Also da sind ein paar Fragezeichen. Für uns beobachtet er natürlich spannend, wie sich Girona dann mit der Doppelbelastung, mit vielleicht leicht anderem Kader nächstes Jahr präsentieren wird. Alex Garcia wird ja auch von Leverkusen umworben. Oder soll der auf dem Weg dahin sein, wird wahrscheinlich zu Leverkusen wechseln. Ist auch ein absoluter Schlüsselspieler, zentraler Spieler, kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen, eine Top-Verpflichtung für Leverkusen werden. Dann freue ich mich brutal darauf, den in der Bundesliga zu sehen.
Den kannte ja keiner, würde es dann in einem Dreivierteljahr wieder heißen. Der Oli würde den nicht kennen. Aber sag mal, weil der Trainer, du hast es ja schon gesagt, wir haben ja über Michel auch schon gesprochen, also ein europäisch völlig unbeschriebenes Blatt. Und auch lokal, weil jetzt nicht so, dass alle gesagt haben, oh jetzt rüstet Girona aber auf, jetzt passiert ja was. Sondern man hat das halt so hingenommen. Dovbek kommt aus der ukrainischen Liga, da hängt natürlich auch noch ein Kontext dran. Trotzdem hat ihn sich auch Girona geholt und nicht jemand anderes.
Musste auch erst mal scouten.
Genau, und das wollte ich nämlich jetzt fragen. Woher kommt diese strategische Planung von Girona? Sind die sehr datenbasiert? Gibt es da eine Person, die einen von sehr guten Riechen hatte? Hatten die jetzt ein bisschen Glück? Also wie kommt zum Beispiel so eine Trainerentscheidung zustande? Lässt er einen Fußball spielen, der gut passt?
Also das sind jetzt zwei Fragen in einem Trainerentscheidung. Den haben sie schon in der 2. Liga geholt. Michelle ist mit ihnen aufgestiegen, über die Playoffs übrigens nur. Also sie wurden nur 6. in La Liga vor 2 Jahren oder vor 3. Sie waren ja letztes Jahr, dann wurden 10. direkt nach dem Aufstieg. Also jetzt im 2. La Liga ja quasi nach dem Aufstieg. Aber sie wurden nur 6. über die Playoffs. Spanien hat ja dieses Playoffsystem, das Rang 3 bis Rang 6 Playoffs ausspielt, wie in England. Und da wurden sie nur, also wenn du nur 6. wirst, hast du meistens genauso viele Spiele gewonnen, wie du verloren hast. Also wirklich, ja, keine besondere Leistung. Aber über die Playoffs kannst du halt hochkommen. Und dass du dann direkt 10. wirst und jetzt direkt 3. wirst, ist schon bemerkenswert. Konnte man so auch nicht absehen. Deswegen ist er wieder der große Name. Noch konnte man das irgendwie vorhersehen, dass wir so explodieren werden. Selbst wenn du sagst, sie haben die City Group im Hintergrund und können dadurch natürlich besser scouten. Da sind dann doch andere Mittel dabei. Du kommst über das Thema nicht drum rum, auch wenn du es vielleicht ein bisschen ausklammern willst. Aber auch ein Beispiel. Jan Couto vor drei Jahren, brasilianisches Rechtsverteidiger-Talent. Zwei Vereine wollten den oder waren an ihm dran. Manchester City und der FC Barcelona. Und er hat sich für Man City entschieden. Und was machen sie? Kaufen ihn für die City Group und verleihen ihn natürlich dann an Girona. Girona würde diesen Spieler nie bekommen, wenn die City Group nicht dahinter gesteckt hätte. Weil er dann bei Barca gelandet wäre. Denn wenn du Brasilianer bist und Real oder Barca wollen dich, gibt es gar keine Frage, wohin du gehst. Aber da war die City Group dahinter. Man City hat halt ein paar Pesos mehr geboten, offenbar. Vielleicht eine bessere Perspektive aufgezeigt auch. Und zack, zwei, drei Jahre später landet er beim FC Girona. Und deswegen, wie ist ihr Scouting? Ja, natürlich super. Aber es hilft auch, die City Group im Rücken zu haben. Da kommst du nicht so ganz drum herum um das Thema.
Und das ist jetzt aber eigentlich die viel wichtigere Frage. Sehe ich das richtig hier aktuell, dass die 2. Liga nicht mehr La Liga Dos heißt, so wie es früher war, sondern die heißt jetzt auch La Liga, nur halt mit einem Sponsor hintendran? Also es gibt jetzt La Liga und es gibt La Liga Sponsoren Namen.
Ja, La Liga eSports ist ja auch schon, die hatte ja auch einen Sponsor, schon die 1. Liga. Und das andere ist Hypermotion. Hypermotion, Hypermotion, ich weiß.
Aber sie heißen beide einfach nur, ja, es ist halt die Liga. Stelle ich halt nicht so an, ob 1 oder 2, ist doch wurscht. Und da scheint es noch ein Sponsor. Das ist dann ein zweitklassiger Sponsor.
Wir driften ab, Max.
Ja, okay, ich merke es schon. Du bist heute mit Disziplin hier mit dabei, das ist ja richtig.
Entschuldigung, einer muss ja.
Ja, ja, ich sehe schon, du hast noch Termine und das ist ja auch richtig so. Dann blicken wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Alexi, was möchtest du uns noch erzählen von dieser Ligue 1-Saison? Was war noch wichtig?
Ja, was wir schon besprochen haben, natürlich das große kam weg von Olympique Lyon. November Letzter, am Ende Sechster. Lyon war jetzt in der Rückrunde die beste Ligamannschaft, genau punktgleich mit PSG, 2,1 Punkte pro Spiel. Und die beste Mannschaft, seit Pierre Sage die Mannschaft übernommen hat, Pierre der Ruhige, Peter der Ruhige, entschuldigung, genau übersetzen. Seit er die Mannschaft übernommen hat vom Idol, von Christian, nämlich der Fabio Grosso im Oktober. Fabio Grosso gefüllt 0,2 Punkte pro Spiel. Und dann kam dieser völlig unbekannte Pierre Sage daher, der die jungen Mannschaften von OL trainiert hatte und hat die Mannschaft an komplett neues Niveau angehoben. Natürlich hat der US-Investor John Dexter dafür gesorgt, dass die Mannschaft verstärkt wird im Winter mit 7 Neuzugängen. Aber nur zwei haben gezündet. Deswegen haben vor allem die alten Wecke, wie Lacazette mit 19 Saison-Treffern, Nicole Nathalie Soe, der sich wieder gesteigert hat in der Rückrunde, auch fitter wurde, die Mannschaft dort stabilisiert und sein Aktionsniveau erreicht. Ich habe schon vorher gesagt, dass wir dann, wenn die richtig angreifen, nicht nur auf dem Transfermarkt, sondern auch in der Liga, weil Peugeot wahrscheinlich wieder sorgbarer sein wird und den Barbet wieder neu finden müssen. Die behalten leider Lucien Riquet, der die Mannschaft komplett an die Wand fahren wird. Aber darüber sprechen wir im September. Und dann ist es natürlich die Chance für Olympique Lyon, weil die nur Europa League bestreiten. Und sicherlich auch einen Kader haben werden, der auch in der Breite passen wird, dass man alle drei Tage performen kann. Und deswegen Lyon ganz klar nachher preist. Das ist nicht eine Überraschung, aber das Comeback des Jahres. Weil das zu schaffen, hätten nicht viele gedacht. Vor allem bei den Fans, wo man schon Angst hatte, in der 2.
Du hast ja damals Gift Orban genannt im Winter und hast gesagt, das ist die entscheidende Verpflichtung. War der auch einer von den beiden, die eingeschlagen sind jetzt?
Überhaupt nicht. Bis heute waren Fremdkörper, Lacazette mit Nuama vorne, gesetzt bei Lyons. Aber Orban hat die ersten zwei, drei Spiele überzeugt. Aber danach war er in Training nicht so Gas gegeben, dass PSG gemeint hat, wenn überhaupt erst nächste Saison. Aber er hat dann wenig Spieleinsätze gehabt. Deswegen gibt Orban bisher wirklich keine Verstärkung. Trotzdem hat Lyons die Erwartungen und Ziel erreicht. Und dazu natürlich auch das Pokalentspiel.
Stimmt, genau, da war man ja auch. Und was für ein Trainer ist Piersas? Jetzt hat man ja ihn eine ganze Rückrunde quasi im Rampenlicht gesehen. Also wie ist er in der Darstellung nach außen? Was für einen Fußball-Lester spielt er?
Er ist erst einmal ein sehr, wie der Name sagt, sehr ruhiger, sehr besonderer Typ, sehr bescheiden. Der aber auch bestimmt ist, er weiß genau, was er will und spielerisch. Er spielt 4-3-3, also ein kompaktes Mittelfeld. Und er setzt auch auf Spieler, die unberechenbar sind, das heißt, dass sie auf verschiedene Positionen angesetzt werden können. Er hat auch keine Angst vor großen Namen, wie Ryan Cherki, wie Dejan Lovren, der auch öfter auf der Bank saß in der Rückrunde, als er auf dem Platz stand. Und das hat er auch gut gemacht, auch im Pokalfinale hat er den künstigen Torwart von Lyon, Lucas Peri, der Brasilianer anstelle von OL Legende, António López, also Portugals Nummer 3, als Stammtorwart designiert auch, sodass López wahrscheinlich den Verein wechseln muss zum ersten Mal in seiner Karriere weg muss nach 33 Jahren. Oder mit 33 Jahren, Entschuldige. Und ich würde damit sagen, Yaksaj ist zwar unerfahren an dem Niveau, aber durch seine ruhige, aber auch bestimmte Art, hat er sich durchgesetzt und deswegen hat auch der strenge, aber bestimmte Investor mit ihm um zwei Jahre verlängert. Und er hat auch noch jetzt in diesen Tagen sein Trainerdiplom in der Tasche und kann also in der Klischthälschen problemlos weiter als Nummer eins arbeiten.
Und hilf mir nochmal kurz, der Investor, den Namen kennt man ja. Hat er noch andere Fußballvereine?
Er hat einige. Also Pistol Palace hat er jetzt verkauft, aber er hat auch Botafogo in Brasilien und Molendek in Belgien, wo der französische Trainer der Mbappé in Becker Bruno Viles nach 21 Tagen entlassen wurde.
Stimmt, genau. Und Pistol Palace war das, wo er quasi früher mit drin hing. Das habe ich mich eben gefragt. Und da ist jetzt aber quasi zu erwarten, weil das so lief, weil du gesagt hast, jetzt im Sommer wird man das so weitermachen wie im Winter. Weil auf der einen Seite ist das nachvollziehbar, wenn man in der Rückrunde auf Augenhöhe mit PSG ist, dann beginnst du natürlich zu träumen und das hochzurechnen. Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, das Ergebnis dieser Saison, nämlich die Europa Conference League, müsste es ja dann geworden sein mit dem 6. Platz, da verdient man jetzt ja noch nicht Geld, auch nicht als Investor. Warum lässt mich kicker.de immer feigen? Ich habe extra nicht Husqvarth aufgemacht, weil das im letzten Jahr das Problem war.
Aber egal, solange sie nicht in der Champions League sind, werden sie nicht wirklich viel Kollekt verdienen können. Aber John Traxtor hat viel Geld. Der wird jetzt sicherlich auch in die Mannschaft investiert, um endlich mal wieder in die Kombinanzierung oder bis 2025, 2026 in der Klinik klar zu sein. Das ist das Mal, wo man in der Champions League dabei war, immerhin im Halbfinale gegen die Bayern in Lissabon. Und die Zuschauer, deswegen ist man froh in Frankreich, dass vielleicht endlich mal ein ernstzunehmender Konkurrent für PSG wächst. Denn wenn man sich die anderen schaut, wie Olandic Marseille immer spielen, dann wird es Jahrzehnten brauchen, bis die wieder Paris Saint-Germain richtig wehtun können.
Also Lyons, wirklich eine interessante Geschichte. Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht wusste, dass sie in die Europa League kommen. Aber ich habe nur die letzten zwei Wochen Bundesliga gemacht. Ihr seid alle neidisch auf meinen Job. Ich weiß das schon. Christian, Serie A, zweites Thema. Über wen wollen wir da noch reden?
Fangen wir mal anleitend an. Bologna und Thiago Motta hätten es mehr als verdient, das zweite Thema zu werden. Wir haben die letzten Wochen schon mehrmals darüber gesprochen. Ich wollte es aber nur kurz mal nennen, weil Bologna sehr souverän in die Champions League gekommen ist. Es ist eine wunderbare Geschichte. Nur, wir hatten oft das Prinzip, mal ein bisschen eine schönere Geschichte, mal ein bisschen eine weniger schöne Geschichte. Ich finde, wenn der Meister des einen Jahres in der Saison darauf Zehntor wird, dann ist das definitiv auch eine Geschichte. Wir müssen jetzt über Napoli reden. Das haben wahrscheinlich alle mitbekommen, sehr viele. Von 1 auf 10, erstmal ein, zwei Daten dazu. Napoli hat zu Hause gleich viele Punkte wie Empoli geholt, die sich am letzten Spieltag gerettet haben. Und, Achtung, ich konnte es nicht glauben, Napoli hat in den Heimspielen eine negative Torbilanz als rampierender Meister. Das nur mal um ein, zwei Zahlen das Ganze einzuleiten. Der klassische Fall, was kann innerhalb eines Jahres alles, was kann man kaputt machen sozusagen, wenn wir jetzt im sportlichen Bereich bleiben. Ungefähr alles passiert, was nur passieren kann. Kurzes Recap, Napoli hat in dieser Saison drei Trainer gehabt. Es wurde Jas Baleti, war ja seine Zeit zu Ende. Rudi Garcia hat angefangen. Dann durfte sich Walter Mazzari kurzzeitig probieren. Und am Ende hat Calzona übernommen, der slowakischer Nationaltrainer ist, der jetzt dann zu M kommt. Der wird froh sein, dass der sich jetzt um die slowakische Nationalmannschaft kümmern darf. Und ja, dieses Kapitel für ihn beendet ist. Calzona noch mal ganz kurz dazu. Er war ja nicht viel im Begriff. Er war aber jahrelang Co-Trainer von Sarri und auch von Spalletti. Also hat dann sozusagen, das war nochmal der Versuch, sozusagen die alten Vibes nochmal rauszuholen. Aber am Ende war er sogar von den drei, der mit einem schlechtesten Punkt erschnitt. Also, keine Ahnung, Napoli, da könnte man jetzt logisch eine ganze Spezialsendung drüber machen. Ich probier's einfach mal ein bisschen zusammenzufangen. Aber wirft eher gerne was rein, was euch dazu einfällt. Und dann probieren wir das halt kurz abzuarbeiten. Es sind unfassbar viele Sachen passiert.
Naja, also ich hätte ja über den Team Präsidenten gesprochen. Das, was mit Napoli passiert ist, natürlich nicht in der Bedeutung, also dass es besonders so krass werden würde. Aber dass es da diesen Umbruch gibt und dass man auch den Meistertrainer wechselt, das war ja schon frühzeitig erkennbar, haben wir hier auch thematisiert. Und das hat ja wesentlich mit ihm auch zu tun. Also ist das jetzt dann auch seine Hauptverantwortung, dass diese Saison so gelaufen ist, wie sie gelaufen ist?
Ja, absolut. Also Aurelio de Laurentiis, der Präsident von Napoli, ein Filmmogul, einer, der die große Bühne liebt. Und einer, muss man jetzt sagen, der diesen unfassbaren Moment, denn das war es letztes Jahr, dass Napoli nach 30 Jahren nach Maradona wieder den Scudetto holt in dieser unfassbar emotionalen Fußball-verrückten Stadt. Das war ja wirklich eine Geschichte, eine schöne Fußballgeschichte einfach. Und de Laurentiis ist halt ein Typ, der, ich sage es jetzt mal, ich drücke es mal so aus, der trotzt vor Selbstbewusstsein. Und der hat in dem Moment dann wahrscheinlich wirklich gedacht, Spalletti weg, Giuntoli weg, die sind nämlich der Sportdirektor, der ist ja auch weg, der ist zu Juve gegangen, der Athletiktrainer ist auch gegangen. Napoli, wir hatten vorhin das Thema Fitness. Napoli hat letztes Jahr auf so vielen Ebenen, waren die großartig, aber eine Ebene, die gar nicht so oft thematisiert wurde, die waren auch unfassbar fit. Die hat nämlich auch genau diese Geschichte, ganz viele Spiele in der zweiten Hälfte entschieden. Also das war auch ein Puzzleteil, aber das wurde logisch nicht groß geredet, weil es wurde über Spalletti und Giuntoli geredet, aber das ist alles weggebrochen. Und der Laurentis hat im Prinzip dann selbst die Entscheidung getroffen. Der Laurentis hat gedacht, er ist jetzt eben nicht nur der Präsident dieses Vereins, sondern er schafft es jetzt auch, das Ganze noch mal weiterhin gut zu machen. Und alle Entscheidungen, die er getroffen hat, im Prinzip waren falsch, oder sehr viele. Er hat es im Prinzip dann auch selbst eingestanden, dann schon Ende des Jahres, glaube ich, kurz vorm Jahreswechsel hat er sich auch öffentlich entschuldigt. Aber ja, wie gesagt, ich probiere jetzt nur mal ein paar kleine Geschichten zu erzählen. Rudi Garcia, so ging es schon los. Im Nachhinein, nachdem er Garcia entlassen hatte, da kann Alexi sicherlich auch was dazu sagen, kamen dann so Aussagen von de Laurentis, der meinte, ich habe eigentlich schon nach 10 Tagen, als Garcia da war, gemerkt, das klappt nicht. Eigentlich hätte ich ihn da schon rauswerfen müssen. Also, jetzt muss man dazu sagen, die Aussagen von de Laurentis, wie gesagt, das ist ein sehr spezieller Typ, ob man die jetzt alle für bare Münster nehmen muss, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber Fakt ist, er hat diese Personalentscheidung getroffen. Er hat sich einen schwachen Sportdirektor geholt, der im Prinzip keine große Entscheidungsgewalt hatte. Dementsprechend ist er derjenige, der das zu verantworten hat. Definitiv, kurzes Kapitel dazu noch. Im Winter, also von dieser Meistermannschaft war wirklich nur Kim weg. Bei Kim hatten sie auch keine Möglichkeit. Kim, der zu Bayern gegangen ist, der hatte diese Klausel, da waren ihnen die Hände gebunden. Aber sie haben Ozymen gehalten, sie haben Quara gehalten. Sie haben ja wirklich sehr viel getan, um sozusagen auch im nächsten Jahr noch mal zumindest eine gute Rolle zu spielen. Und im Winter hat er dann noch mal, es passt auch wunderbar rein, wilde Transfers, also wirklich einfach nur Sachen gemacht. Das eine Symbol ist den Donker, ehemaliger belgischer Nationalspieler. Den holen die im Winter. Und der ist am Ende auf 31 Spielminuten gekommen. Also kein Mensch weiß, den kannst du gar nicht bewerten, weil er einfach nicht gespielt hat. Und das ist zum Beispiel eine dieser vielen Geschichten, so ein kleines Symbol. Da hat er noch mal Geld rausgeworfen, planlos, wild. Das hat auch in keinster Weise dazu geführt, dass die jetzt in der Rückrunde noch mal vielleicht, weil immer so ein bisschen die Hoffnung war, die werden schon irgendwann kommen. Die werden vielleicht noch Richtung Champions League-Quali schnuppern, aber sonst halt Europa League. Aber nein, es ging immer weiter nach unten. Platz 10 als amtierender Meister, gab es Ewigkeiten nicht mehr in Italien. Wirklich viele Spieler, die sicherlich am vergangenen Saison auch ein paar über ihrem Niveau gespielt haben, da hat einfach alles gepasst. Deswegen möchte ich jetzt auch noch mal die Spieler anreißen. Ja, De Laurentiis ist der erste Verantwortliche, keine Frage. Und ja, ich weiß, dass für einen Spieler, wenn du in einer Saison drei Trainer hast, dass das alles andere als ideal ist, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Aber ich finde, auch viele Spieler haben den Club und die Stadt auch ein bisschen, sozusagen dieses, ich will es jetzt nicht zu groß machen, nicht im Stich gelassen, aber meiner Meinung nach, gerade in den letzten Wochen und Monaten ist das bei mir gereift. Die Mannschaft, die Spieler hatten schon auch einen sehr, sehr großen Anteil daran. Denn ich finde gerade Carl Zona eben, das war dann wirklich der dritte Trainer, den kannten sie, den kannten viele noch. Der hat genau diese Spielprinzipien, die Sari und Spalletti, Napoli auf diesen Weg gebracht. Da habe ich mir echt gedacht, jetzt haben die Spieler keine Ausreden mehr. Und auch da haben sie nicht geliefert. Dementsprechend, einer darf vielleicht sinnbildlich, Anguissat, erinnern Sie sich vielleicht noch ein paar Vergangenen, so herausragend, wie er mit Cielinski und Lobotka im Mittelfeld wirklich diese Physis verkoppert hat. Anguissat ist in dieser Saison oft, unter Anführungszeichen, manchmal über den Platz spaziert. Und das, finde ich, war wirklich bitter, weil die Fans waren immer da. Und es gab am Ende wirklich 5 Konzerte zu Recht auch. Noch mal, Napoli ist eine sehr spezielle Fußballstadt. Und da haben sich wirklich, jeden glaube ich in Neapel, war klar, dass die das nicht mal dieses Märchen wiederholen. Das hat auch keiner erwartet. Aber zwischen 1 und 10 liegen halt nicht nur ein Welten, sondern ich würde sagen, da liegen mehrere Welten und dementsprechend. Ja, wirklich krasse Geschichte, wie du innerhalb eines Jahres sowas sozusagen sportlich runterwärtschaffen kannst.
Ich habe zwei kurze Anschlussfragen.
Sehr gerne.
Die erste, die mir unter den Nägeln brennt, ist, wann zieht Max die Parallelen zu Uli Hoeneß? Wenn man sich aber noch vorstellen würde, on top, dass Uli Hoeneß wirklich auch Manager, Sportdirektor, alles im Personalunwohnt wäre.
Er hat doch gesagt, dass der Laurent ist, oft Sachen sagt, die man so nicht ernst nehmen kann, weil sie ein bisschen zu pointiert sind. Wo ist denn da die Parallel? Da war für mich der Höhenesvergleich völlig...
Das war die eine Frage, die ich habe. Und die andere ist, ist es korrekt, dass neun italienische Mannschaften in Europa spielen und Napoli am letzten Spieltag sogar trotzdem noch die Chance auf Europa hatte durch ein Heimspiel und nur unentschieden spielte und deswegen sogar als zehntel oder neunter Europa verpasst hat, obwohl sie es noch hätten schaffen können?
Nicht ganz. Es bestand die Möglichkeit, wenn die Fiorentina das Conference League-Finale gewonnen hätte, dann hätte auch noch Platz 9 gereicht, dann wäre genau das, was du hier sagst, eingetreten. Dadurch sind es jetzt nur 8, unter Anführungszeichen, und dementsprechend, und damit möchten wir jetzt, wir können auch schon einen kleinen Blick nach vorne werfen, die große Frage war dann ja auch, und das hat der Laurentis glaube ich wirklich verstanden, er hat verstanden in dieser Saison, dass seine Rolle, dass er sich da komplett übernommen hat. Und wir dürfen, der Laurentis auch, das wäre eine eigene Sendung wert, das ist ein sehr spezieller Typ, ich drücke es mal so aus. Nur was man nicht vergessen darf, der hat halt viele Jahre auch dazu beigetragen, Napoli da hinzubringen, wo die letztes Jahr waren. Der hat nämlich viele richtige Personalentscheidungen getroffen. Der hat manchmal genau eben den Spallettis und den Giuntolis machen lassen und die nochmal, Napoli ist auch eine der wirtschaftlich gesündesten Mannschaften in Italien. Also da war die letzten Jahre auch viel Gutes dabei. Nur dieses Jahr ist halt alles in die Hose gegangen. Und deswegen war jetzt schon seit Monaten und Wochen die große Frage, wen holen die als Trainer? Was passiert? Und jetzt wird immer, es ist anscheinend wirklich nur noch vor der Unterschrift, Antonio Conte wird kommen. Und das ist schon, ja, das ist sehr spannend. Denn ich war logisch auch monatelang, dachte ich mir, nee, Conte kommt, also Conte und der Fußball, den Napoli jetzt seit Jahren gespielt hat, viel weiter auseinander geht nicht. Nur mittlerweile muss ich sagen, bin ich am Punkt, da geht es darum, eine Fußballmannschaft, einen Fußballclub, fußballerisch wiederzubeleben. Also da ist alles am Boden sozusagen. Und da gibt es einen, der das schon oft bewiesen hat, dass er es kann und das ist Antonio Conte. Der hat es bei Juve eben damals, seine Serie gestartet. Bei Chelsea ist er Meister geworden, glaube ich, als sie nicht europäisch waren. Und jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt. Das ist ein Glücksfall, dass Napoli nächstes Jahr nicht europäisch spielen wird. Denn jetzt kommt dieser Fakt, da kommt Conte hin. Conte wird einen gewaltigen Tritt in den Hintern. Sehr viele Menschen da sozusagen mitgeben. Und die können Woche für Woche nur alle anderen vorne haben Doppelbelastung, eben Mannschaften wie Bologna, die das noch nicht kennen. Ganz viele Fragezeichen bei vielen großen Klubs. Neue Trainer, Milan neuer Trainer, Juve neuer Trainer, Bologna neuer Trainer. Und dann kommt dieser Antonio Conte dahin und der wird Feuer machen. Da bin ich fest davon überzeugt. Und Conte ist aus Apulien, also aus der Bari-Gegend. Er ist ein Mann des Südens, der weiß, wie der Süden tickt. Und ich bin mir sicher, ich prognostiziere, dass Napoli nächstes Jahr mit Conte wieder in die Champions League mitspielen. Weil sie eben dieses Woche für Woche nur haben. Mittlerweile glaube ich wirklich, ihr müsst Conte holen, weil du da wirklich einen Klub sozusagen fußballerisch wiederbeleben musst. Ich bin wahnsinnig gespannt. Zweiter Punkt dazu, das darf man auch nicht vergessen, wenn einer wie Conte kommt, bedeutet das, dass die ihm nicht alles verkaufen werden. Weil sonst wird er nicht kommen. Der Punkt ist, die werden Ocimene zu Geld machen. Das weiß man seit Wochen und Monaten. Aber ich bin mir zum Beispiel sicher, dass einer wie Quara, der jetzt logischerweise auch überall auf dem Zettel steht, da kann Alexis vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu den Paris-Geschichten sagen, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass einer, wenn Conte unterschreibt, dann gehen da nicht drei, vier wichtige Spieler. Sonst würde der gar nicht erst kommen. Und wenn du dann jetzt mit dieser gesunden wirtschaftlichen Situation, weil die hat Napoli, wenn du die Ossimen-Millionen gut investierst, muss logisch wieder einen guten Mittelstürmer die organisieren, aber wie gesagt, die letzten Jahre haben die viele gute Entscheidungen auch getroffen und dann lässt du Conte Woche für Woche arbeiten, ich glaube, das kann was werden.
Das ist ein sehr guter Gestalt.
Von der Gemengelage sozusagen her. Auch wenn noch mal taktisch logischerweise, also jetzt kommt ein harter Cut bei Napoli. Nach den Sarri-Jahren und Spaletti-Jahren brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden, aber ich glaube im Moment, da ist so viel kaputt gegangen, sozusagen immer, Fußballer ist logischerweise gesprochen, dass Conte in der Situation jetzt glaube ich wirklich einer ist, der da dieses Feuer wieder entfachen kann.
Feuer gibt er dir aber auch im negativen Sinne, wenn er nicht die Rückendeckung des Sportmanagements hat, das Präsidium des sportlichen Leiters, wie auch immer, wenn da nicht De Laurentiis an einem Strang zieht mit Conte oder andersrum, dann wird es ungemütlich.
Gar keine Frage, aber auch da, ich meine De Laurentiis hat das in den letzten Jahren ja bewiesen und noch mal gerade Junto in Spalletti dort arbeiten lassen. Und ich glaube, wenn er jetzt Conte holt, das sind auch Summen im Raum, also Conte ist ein teurer Trainer, also da muss jetzt De Laurentiis auch tief in die Tasche greifen. Und er wäre wirklich doppelt schlecht beraten, wenn er De Laurentiis dann das auch wieder von relativ von außen versucht zu torpedieren. Wenn das passiert, dann kann es logisch völlig an die Wand fahren. Brauchen wir gar nicht reden. Aber ich glaube, nach der Erfahrung von De Laurentiis jetzt auch in dem Jahr, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass selbst so ein Mann wie der die Größe hat zu sehen, okay, jetzt probieren wir es mal und jetzt kommt eben dieser Mann, wo er weiß, wie auch der tickt, lassen wir den doch vielleicht mal machen. Ansonsten, wie du sagst, Alex, wenn das auch logisch, wenn die zwei Charaktere aneinander geraten, ja, dann explodiert es logisch nächstes Jahr, so noch mal, gar keine Frage. Aber ich würde sagen, die Gemengelage ist jetzt wirklich so, dass ich mittlerweile sage, wow, lasst den den Funken nur ein bisschen anzünden. Ich meine, die Napoli-Fans, die lechzen ja nur danach, dass die wieder ein paar gute Momente haben und wenn die merken, dass die Mannschaft und das, man konnte viel vorwerfen, aber die werden wieder arbeiten, die werden wieder Präsenz auf dem Feld zeigen und das, glaube ich, kann dann auch das Publikum mitnehmen. Deswegen, ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt.
Und man darf eben nicht vergessen, Napoli kommt wirklich jetzt aus einer krassen Schwächephase. Der Abstand zum Meister Inter sind 41 Punkte.
Unfassbar.
Mit diesen 41 Punkten wäre Napoli 13. geworden. Also der Abstand des letzten Meisters und diesjährigen Meisters ist quasi die Saison von Hellas. Das ist schon wirklich krass. Also jetzt hast du mich auch angezündet. Also jetzt habe ich auch Bock auf Konter bei Napoli. Aber das ist dann ein Thema der Zukunft. Wir haben noch ein Thema in La Liga. Über wen willst du noch sprechen, Alex?
Ja, wenn wir von einem ganz großen, illustren Trainernamen sprechen, der nach Italien geht, müssen wir natürlich über den anderen grandiosen, großen Trainer sprechen, der nach Spanien geht, Max.
Ich weiß, da hast du richtig Bock.
Über den Ex-Bayerentrainer und den Ex-Bundestrainer zu sprechen, der jetzt einen anderen, nicht ganz so tief gefallenen Verein, aber auch ganz großen Verein natürlich beleben soll. Die Rede ist natürlich von Hansi Flick, der zum FC Barcelona wechselt. Das ist ein riesiges Thema, das man natürlich so ein bisschen stricken kann, weil es ja auch so turbulent war bei Barca in der Saison. Weil man muss natürlich über das Thema Schavi sprechen, wie sein Abgang der ja erst der gefeierte Meistertredner. Also um es jetzt minimal nur nachzuerzählen. Das hat ja eh die gesamte deutsche Journal, die Presse hat es ja gecovert, aber nur um es mal nachzuerzählen. Er kam ja als der Heiland, als der vermeintlich neue Pep. So wurde es ja ein bisschen erhofft, thematisiert, berichtet. Und dann wurde er gleich Meister und ja sehr souverän. Und dann plötzlich war komplett die Souveränität wirklich hinüber in der Hinrunde. Mit vielen, vielen biederen Auftritten, mit vielen ernüchternden Ergebnissen auch. Vor allem auswärts haben sie oft Punkte gelassen. Dann haben sie den Klassiker nach verloren, obwohl sie geführt haben, unglücklich irgendwie aus der Hand gegeben. Gegen Girona haben sie zu Hause verloren. Mit, ich glaube, 2 zu 4, gegen Villarreal 3 zu 5 verloren. Also war natürlich auch die Art und Weise. Und dann plötzlich hast du gemerkt, Hoppla, der wackelt richtig. Und dann ist er auf einmal zurückgetreten im Januar. Also vielleicht auch so ein bisschen aus Selbstschutz. Bevor ihr entlassen werdet, dreht ihr lieber zurück. Man weiß es nicht. Und dann hat der FC Barcelona unter Präsident Joan Laporta in Wohl offenbar überredet, fast schon angebettelt. Bleibt doch bitte. Und dann hat er seine Meinung geändert. Und 3 Wochen später hat Barca seine Meinung geändert.
Aber wann haben sie ihn überredet? Kannst du mir das nochmal sagen? Weil es war ja so, diese Schwächephase hast du ja genannt. Da war ja noch dieses 3 zu 5 zu Hause gegen Villarreal. Das haben wir, glaube ich, auch hier zumindest mal thematisiert. Und dann aber ist man ja zum Beispiel gegen Neapel in der Champions League weitergekommen. Und auch absolut verdient. Man hatte bessere Ergebnisse. Kam es erst dann, dass dann La Porta gesagt hat, Mensch, Xavi, also ich habe dich immer gemocht, magst du nicht hierbleiben?
Er hat ja gesagt, der Druck ist so groß, die Mannschaft braucht wohl eine Veränderung. Er muss den Druck von der Mannschaft nehmen. Das waren ja so die Gründe, die er verkauft hat, so thematisiert hat. Also auch der Druck auf ihn selbst. Bei Barca ist ja wirklich immer sehr viel Druck auf dem Kessel. Medial, Anspruchshaltung des Präsidiums, die politischen Grabenkämpfe innerhalb des Vereins, sehr aufgeblasen immer alles. Also ein bisschen HSV-mäßig fast schon, was immer bei Barca hinter den Kulissen losgeht. Wenn der Erfolg nicht so da ist, dann natürlich nochmal Erwartungshaltung umfällt, mediale Druck mit drei Radiosendern, sieben Zeitungen, dies, das. Also es ist ein bisschen wie bei den Bayern, wenn es nicht läuft, was da immer los ist. Und das hat ihn auch zermürbt, sicherlich. Und deswegen hat er dann aufgehört. Und genau wie du es gesagt hast, danach haben sich die Ergebnisse wieder eingestellt, also positiverweise. Dann haben sie irgendwie 13 Spiele oder so, plus, minus in Folge umgeschlagen, zehn oder elf davon gewonnen, Champions League weitergekommen, auch sehr verdient. Sie hätten ja schon in Neapel, wir haben glaube ich darüber gesprochen, Bernie, schon gewinnen können, zumindest im Rückspiel, dann haben sie es wirklich verdient gemacht, haben sich also stabilisiert. Und dann hast du gemerkt, hey Hoppla, vielleicht ist das doch noch nicht zu Ende, erzählt die Geschichte. Zumindest dachte man das offenbar im Verein. Ja, und dann gab es wieder eine Klassikoniederlage, auch wieder unglücklich, aber das ist halt auch Real Madrid, wieder in der 90. Mit auch der ein oder anderen Schiri-Entscheidung, die man jetzt...
Das kann ich mir bei Real überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Und ja, dann haben sie wieder gegen Girona verloren, wieder gegen Nachführung. Und dann, ja, das geht halt schnell bei Barcelona. Zwei große Spiele, sehr, sehr wichtiges Spiel gegen Girona. Denn dann ging es um Platz 2. Platz 2 ist ja, den haben sie jetzt erreicht, aber das ist ja die Teilnahme am Supercup mit sehr, sehr viel Prestige, aber auch Millionen verbunden. Also wir reden da von wirklich 20 Millionen, die man mehr hat oder nicht mehr hat, wenn man zweiter wird, all around genommen. Also sehr, sehr wichtig, finanziell zweiter zu werden. Und das haben sie dann verloren im direkten Vergleich. Dann zog Girona davon und dann zack, wieder Krisenstimmung. Und da haben sie offenbar entschieden, ja, nee, die Art und Weise, wie ihr euch präsentiert habt, wieder unter Xavi. Das ist doch nicht, doch nicht so zielführend. Und dann binnen drei Wochen haben sie ihre Meinung geändert und ihn dann doch wieder enteiert. Denn ja, im Hintergrund wurde dann mit Hansi Flick mal wieder verhandelt oder gesprochen. Und die Medien haben schon berichtet, Hansi wird es wahrscheinlich, man ist sehr weit. Und Xavi wusste vor nichts, denn er hat ja vor zwei Wochen erst seinen Vertrag, oder nicht seinen Vertrag verlängert, aber den Rücktritt vom Rücktritt vollzogen. Er hat ja noch Vertrag gehabt bis 2025. Und dann hat er gesagt, den erfüllt er. Und sie haben ja feierlich verkündet auf der PK. Also es war ja wirklich fast schon wie so ein Trainer oder Spielertransfer, wo alle sich die Hand geben und um die Wette strahlen. Und das Projekt ist noch nicht beendet. Und wir wollen positiv in die Zukunft schauen. Und die Mannschaft kann mithalten und kann um Titel mitspielen. Das Projekt Xavi geht weiter. Und dann zwei schlechte Ergebnisse plus offenbar ein gegenüber der Presse zu ehrlicher Auftritt von Xavi, haben die Meinung von Laporta und Co wieder geändert. Denn so hieß es, also sie haben wohl ausgemacht, dass sie ein positives Bild nach außen transportieren wollen. Die Mannschaft ist wettbewerbsfähig. Die Mannschaft kann um alle Titel mitspielen. Der Kader ist stark genug. Wir wollen Real Madrid da angreifen. Wir wollen so weit wie möglich kommen, so viele Titel wie möglich gewinnen. Das war die interne Absprache, dass sie quasi positives transportieren an die Medien, an die Fans nach außen generell. Das stellt sich, glaube ich, eine Woche später, vier Tage später, was auch immer, Xavi vor die Presse und sagt, die finanzielle Lage ist schwer, mit Real Madrid mithalten, schwer Titel erwarten, klappt nicht so. Das hat Laporta dann offenbar auch so gestunken, weil Xavi quasi sich gegen interne Absprachen verhalten hat, also dieses positive Bild nicht nach außen transportiert hat, wie man es eigentlich wollte. Das torpediert hat, wenn man so möchte, diese Absprache, diese Positivismus. Und dann plus die schlechten Ergebnisse. Und dann haben sie sich wieder von Xavi getrennt.
Darf ich schnell von außen... Sorry, nur wirklich. Also von außen das betrat. Also ich fand das wirklich diese letzten Monate, ich fand das wieder auf Fußballerisch logisch geworden, das wirklich unwürdig. Ich weiß, dass Barcelona... Du hast das ja wunderbar erzählt. Da war immer oder ist immer schon, was kann viel los sein. Aber diese Xavi-Geschichte hier... Also muss ich echt sagen, ich dachte mir ein paar Mal, ne, das passiert nicht wirklich. Und es ist dann wirklich nochmal die nächste Abfolge gekommen. Und noch eine kleine Beobachtung wieder von außen, weil das Napolispiel angesprochen wurde, oder die Napolis-Serie. Das war ja wirklich da, wo es bei Barca wieder... Okay, die sind jetzt wieder da. Und ja, ich bin bei euch, Barca ist verdient weitergekommen. Aber selbst in dem, im Rückspiel, als Napoli das 2-1 macht, dann gab es zwei, drei Chancen von Napoli, die hätten das 2-2 auch machen können. Absolut. Nochmal, das war verdient. Aber ich finde, dieses Spiel hat mir auch so ein bisschen wirklich diese Instabilität von Barca, finde ich, gezeigt. Auch so ein bisschen sinnbildlich. Obwohl es ja wieder eine gute Phase war. Und nochmal, wir reden über dieses Napoli dieser Saison. Hatten wir ja gerade vorhin. Also selbst da war es einen kleinen Tick wackelig. Auch wenn es dann am Ende völlig okay war, dass Barca weitergekommen ist. Aber ich finde, das beschreibt vielleicht auch ein bisschen, wie sensibel dieses ganze Konstrukt dann wirklich war.
Absolut. Ja, Instabilität ist wirklich das Wort schlechthin. Das hat man nochmal in den Klassikos gesehen. Gegen Girona vor allem gesehen. Und auch gegen Napoli gesehen. Auch gegen PSG natürlich. Da können wir jetzt Alexi mit ins Boot nehmen. Sie haben dieser Schlagabtausch in Paris im Prinzenpark. Da hast du alles gesehen. Das gute Barca, das schlechte in einem Spiel. Sie gewinnen da 3 zu 2, liegen aber hinten. Können durch den Beleg, glaube ich, das wäre das 1 zu 3 gewesen, wenn ich täusche. Dieser Pfostenschuss. Und treffen dann nach einer Ecke. Dann gewinnen sie auswärts, wo du sagst, das ist ein Monster-Resultat für dieses fragile Barca. Verlieren das Rückspiel aber nach Führung 1 zu 4, weil sie immer wieder die Nerven verlieren, weil sie eine rote Karte sehen, weil sie nicht stabil sind, auf gut Deutsch. Und diese Instabilität war quasi die Geschichte, die sportliche Geschichte dieser Saison bei Barca. Und das hat im Endeffekt dann Xavi auch oder hauptsächlich den Posten gekostet.
Und das ist ja quasi die eine Sicht dieser ganzen Abläufe, die du geschildert hast, die ist nachvollziehbar. Also das ist ja bei Scott jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal ein Team, das quasi durch die Saison trudelt. Und dann entscheiden sich die sportlichen Entscheidungsträger mehrmals um. Okay, meinetwegen. Aber was mich wirklich fassungslos macht, ist, dass Hansi Flick jetzt die Antwort auf die Fragen, auf die viele Fragen gestellt hat. Und das waren nämlich diese absurde Komponente, weshalb ich das immer eigentlich glauben konnte. Also es hieß ja dann, Xavi hat grad gesagt, okay, ich bleib und so weiter. Und dann Pressekonferenz und dann ging es ja schon wieder los. Ah, vielleicht jetzt doch, jetzt kommt Hansi Flick doch. Und ich dachte mir immer so, ne, das kann ja gar nicht sein. Weil ich mir immer gedacht hab, ja, warum sollte man denn Xavi durch Hansi Flick ersetzen wollen? Das ist ja selbes Regalfach, selber Anzug, selber weirder Look. Aber vielleicht bin ich doch... Bitte?
Kann er überhaupt Spanisch? Das muss man jetzt natürlich für die, der Kontext fehlt, ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Hansi Flick hat in Deutschland mittlerweile einen anderen Ruf als in Spanien mit anderen Worten. Der Ruf in Deutschland ist nicht ganz so gut wie in Spanien. In Spanien hat er immer noch den Ruf, der Champions League-Sieger, der Triple-Sieger, oder Sechs-Double-Sieger sogar, Max, glaube ich, zu sein. Der Trainer zu sein, der, glaube ich, auch ungeschlagen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, die Champions League gewonnen hat, und der Barca mit 2 zu 8 oder 8 zu 2 aus Bayern sich überrollt hat. Also, dass er den Titel gewonnen hat, ist immer das eine. Damit schmückt man sich natürlich, oder das nimmt man nochmal an. Das war aber auch die Art und Weise, er hat offenbar Laporta nachhaltig. Wir haben ja jetzt was, 5 Jahre später, 4, keine Ahnung, nachhaltig beeindruckt, sodass er eh schon seit Jahren quasi immer wieder damit geliebeugelt hat, einen deutschen Coach zu verpflichten, weil er quasi sehr, sehr viel von den deutschen Trainern hält. Also wir reden da von Nagelsmann, von Klopp, von Tuchel und von Flick. Das ist so eine Trainergarde, von denen er sehr, sehr viel hält. Und Nagelsmann konnte es nicht bekommen. Tuchel war ihm jetzt, ja, das war zu kurzfristig und auch zu instabil. Weil bei Bayern hast du ja selbst gemerkt, so richtig stabil waren die Bayern unter ihm auch nicht. Und Flick war halt frei. Flick ist vor allem bei Pini Zahavi unter Vertrag jetzt neu, dem Superberater, der sehr, sehr gut befreundet ist mit Laporta, die sehr, sehr eng vernetzt sind. Und wenn man Laporta kennt, weiß man, der pflegt Freundschaften oder ein Netzwerk zu seinen Fahrensmännern, sage ich mal, sehr, sehr eng. Zu Jorge Mendes zum Beispiel, der hat die ganzen Portugiesen, Joao Felix, Joao Cancelo, hingelotst zu Barca, weil Laporta dem, ja, ich sage es jetzt mal extra lapidar, aus der Hand frisst. Der hat halt ein offenes Ohr und da lässt er sich einflüstern. Und das ist bei Vinicius Javi das Gleiche. Der ist auch bei Lewandowski unter, oder das ist der Berater von Lewandowski. Und jetzt kann man Personal in Lewandowski halten, was man wollte, aber man hat damals für einen was? 34-Jährigen 50 Millionen gezahlt, 40 plus 10. Mit einem dreieinhalb-Jahres-Vertrag ausgestattet. Also das muss man auch als Kontext wissen. Da steckt Vinicius Javi dahinter. Er steckt im Ohr von Laporta. Laporta hat ein Faible für deutsche Trainer. Laporta wollte auch unbedingt was Neues. Also hat halt gemerkt, in ihrem alten katalanischen Saft steckt die Mannschaft jetzt. Und er wollte auch eine andere Arbeitsweise. Und er sieht halt Flix Bayern als die Monster-Pressing Bayern, die alles erdrückt haben in Europa. Und deswegen hält er von Hansi Flick halt viel mehr als wir mittlerweile in Deutschland. Weil wir eben auch die Doku gesehen haben. In Spanien hat die niemand auf dem Schirm. Weil wir natürlich das auch medial mitbekommen haben, wie sich Deutschland präsentiert hat. Bei der WM, aber auch rund um die WM, nach der WM. Also auch medial öffentlich, wie sich Flick da sehr unsouverän präsentiert hat. Das kriegen die Spanier auch noch mal nicht mit.
Auch beim FC Bayern damals schon. Also diese Endphase natürlich war Salihamidžić eher der böse Bube, der ihn entlassen hat, wo es ja eigentlich auch ganz gut lief. Aber die pumpige Art und Weise von Hansi Flick. Ja, freiwillig war es nicht. Also ja, war damals beidesseitiges Einvernehmen. Und sie haben es dann nach dem Wolfsburgsspiel gesagt. Aber er hat es doch damals dann bei Sky verkündet. Obwohl die Absprache war, dass es der FC Bayern irgendwie ein paar Tage später macht. Und das wurde ja später dann... Also diese ganzen Sportdokus sind ja wirklich nicht mehr anzugucken. Und auch diese Amazon Prime Doku über den FC Bayern war grottenschlecht. Aber das hat man wenigstens gesehen, wie sie es dann in der Halbzeit gesagt haben. Das war der große Spannungsbogen der ganzen Doku. Damit ist sie eingestiegen und dann Cutback zur Saison. Was ist da eigentlich passiert? Und dann haben sie diese Geschichte erzählt, ohne sie zu erzählen. Also war fürchterlich irrelevant. Man erinnert sich an nichts mehr. Aber an diese Szene eben, wie er in Wolfsburg sagt, in der Kabine nach dem Sieg. Also ich wollte euch sagen, wir haben uns darauf geeinigt, dass wir auseinandergehen nach der Saison. Und Salihamidzic guckt nur auf den Boden. Und Hansi Flick geht als nächstes zu Sky und sagt, ich wollte übrigens noch was sagen, ich gehe. Und dann, großes Problem. Und da saßen alle Aufsichtsräte schon im Flieger zurück nach München. Deswegen konnte der FC Bayern nicht offiziell darauf reagieren. Das war die Nummer dazu. Aber was ich so interessant finde, ist eine Beobachtung, die ich gemacht habe. Nämlich, ich habe das nicht verstanden. Und vielleicht bin ich da aber auch zu flick kritisch. Vielleicht gehe ich da auch zu leicht auf den einfachen Witz, den man machen kann. Will ich jetzt auch ganz ehrlich sein. Es ist sehr einfach, darüber Witze zu machen. Was ich aber gesehen habe in spanischen Medien und vor allem bei Fans war, dass die sich vor allem sehr auf die Physis freuen. Ich habe zum Beispiel ein Video gesehen, wo extrem durchtrainierte Bodybuilder auf höchste Geschwindigkeit auf Laufbändern laufen. Dann stand da drüber auf Katalanischer. Also so sieht die Kabine jetzt schon aus. Einfach nur, weil sie wissen, dass Flick kommt. Und interessanterweise hatten wir ja diesen Aspekt vorhin, dass du gesagt hast, real, die waren eigentlich, wenn man so draufschaut, die fitteste, das fitteste Team in der Liga. Vielleicht geht es ja tatsächlich um solche Grundlagen. Und dann muss man ja auch sagen, naja, die eine Beobachtung, nämlich, dass Bayern damals das fitteste Team war. Wir wissen halt, weil auch die Corona-Situation in Deutschland eine andere war als in allen anderen.
Bundesliga hat früher angefangen, ne?
Genau, sie waren besser, sie hatten eine kurze Pause. Und sie haben aber auch während der Corona-Phase, wo es keine Spiele gab, haben sie sehr gut trainiert. Also, das habe ich danach noch von mehreren Leuten gehört, die gesagt haben, Bayern war einfach im Champions League-Turnier damals das fitteste Team. Aber das stimmt ja, und gleichzeitig scheint es ja auch einen Bedarf zu erfüllen, den Barca hat. Also, vielleicht funktioniert es ja auch.
Ja, also das ist der Punkt, ne? Öffentliche Wahrnehmung hast du jetzt auch wieder gesagt, oder habe ich auch ausgeführt, die ist einfach eine andere. Und sei es nur, dass man jetzt Muskelpakete aus dem Pedris und Co. macht, weil man, und ja, Laminha Malz, der 16, ist der natürlich so, ist, weil man dieses Bild hat von Goretzka, wie er damals kam und wie er jetzt aussieht, ob das jetzt an Hansi Flick liegt oder nicht, mag ich nicht beurteilen. Aber das ist die öffentliche Wahrnehmung in Spanien. Also der macht uns fit, dass wir ein hohes Pressing haben werden, dass wir anlaufen werden, dass wir Vollgas geben, das ist auch die Wahrnehmung und die Erwartungshaltung und die Hoffnung natürlich auch. Also dass wir einfach, ja, bissiger sind, laufstärker sind, fitter sind. Das ist die Hoffnung, die man dann hat im Verein, aber auch medial und wahrscheinlich auch bei den Fans weltweit, ob das jetzt zutrifft. Da bin ich zu weit weg von den Bayern gewesen. Vor allem ist die Flick-Bayern-Zeit ja jetzt auch schon ein bisschen her. Ist ja schon wieder sehr viel passiert bei den Bayern. Also meine Erinnerung ist nicht die beste. Und da war ich nicht nagedruckt dran, um zu sagen, war das so wirklich über die, wie lang war Flick da, zweieinhalb Jahre oder so? Oder war das wirklich nur in dieser Champions League Bubble? Schwer zu sagen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall die Hoffnung, die man bei Barca hat. Und wie gesagt, dieser frische Wind, so aus dem, wie soll ich sagen, aus dem katalanischen Sud mal rauskommen, aus diesem, man schwimmt immer nur in seiner Suppe, macht immer das Gleiche und vielleicht mal von außen mal einen neuen Impact, einen neuen Input haben. Vielleicht ist das nicht ganz so schlecht. Und das ist, glaube ich, schon das, was sich Laporta und Co. erhoffen oder was sie meinen, dass die Mannschaft wohl braucht. Aber ob das funktioniert, ich wurde angesprochen, Spanisch spricht er nicht. Er lernt wohl seit, keine Ahnung, zwei Monaten oder drei Spanisch. Hat sich deswegen jetzt tatsächlich, ich habe es ja vorhin kurz erwähnt, Heiko Westermann ins Boot geholt, weil der Spanisch wohl fließend sprechen kann. Und sie wollten unbedingt einen, der Spanisch und Deutsch kann, um da auf dem Platz dann, und Englisch natürlich hoffe ich mal, denke ich mal, dass er auch kann, um da übersetzen zu können. Ich wusste nicht, dass Heiko Westermann fließend Spanisch kann, aber so wurde es berichtet. Aber es ist schon ein bisschen komisch, von Hansi Flick und Heiko Westermann beim FC Barcelona zu sprechen. Also es fällt mir bis heute nicht schwer, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen schwer zu fassen.
Also ich bin mir auch sicher, das wird noch ein Thema sein. Also Hansi Flick beim FC Barcelona, das wird nicht unbemerkt an uns vorbeigehen. Da werden wir auch in der nächsten Saison drüber sprechen. Aber ich fand es schön, dass wir das hier nochmal thematisiert haben. Vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen zu emotional. Ich meine, die Doku war ja auch nicht grottenschlecht. Sie war einfach nur so, wie halt Sport-Dokus sind. Also es gibt den Anschein, dass es quasi... Die Bayern-Doku. Die Deutschland-Doku war spektakulär, aber nur, weil das, was da passiert ist, spektakulär war. Bei der Bayern-Doku hat halt der Verein nochmal drauf geguckt. Das hast du halt gemerkt. Deswegen, da können ja dann auch viele nicht, die so eine Doku machen, nichts dazu. Aber da ist halt dann... Also, da ist kaum eine kritische Aussage drin. Und die Büros, in denen Oli Kahn, Herbert Heine usw. gefilmt werden, da liegt kein Blatt Papier auf dem Tisch, weil alles aufgeräumt ist. Und dementsprechend kannst du von so einer Doku nichts erwarten. Und bei der DFB-Doku, da hatte ganz offensichtlich der DFB keine Möglichkeit, redaktionell mitzuarbeiten. Denn da hast du gesehen, dass das einfach von der Stimmung her und so weiter eine Katastrophe war. Aber vielleicht bin ich da jetzt auch quasi zu emotional. Deswegen, diese Doku im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten, denke ich, ist es schon okay. Ich weiß auch, dass es Leute gibt, die sie gut finden. Ich guck da nochmal ein bisschen kritischer drauf. Ich wollte das nur. Ich glaube, ich bin da ein bisschen derailt an der Stelle. So, wir wollen unsere Saison-Awards noch vergeben. Und wir beginnen mit Alexi. Der darf seine komplett abfrühstücken, denn er muss dann gleich weiter sehr wahrscheinlich mit Zinedine Zidane sprechen, warum das jetzt mit den Bayern-Posten nicht geklappt hat. Das hat dich bewegt, Alexi. Du hast es zweimal erwähnt in dieser Sendung, dass sie dann nicht Trainer von...
Der deutsche Rekordmeister mit dem besten Trainer, der mich beschäftigt, der seit drei Jahren arbeitslos ist, nur weil er nicht Deutsch kann, dann bin ich fassungslos.
Habst du dich wirklich nicht mit ihm beschäftigt?
Kein einziges Mal. Keine einzige Minute und ich habe eine Anekdote dazu aus einem ehemaligen Vorstand. Darf ich aber nicht erzählen, aber das macht die schon wachlos.
Okay, die erzählst du dann bitte in unsere Gruppe nach der Sendung, nach deinem Termin.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dabei mit Sidi, den sie da nicht beschäftigt, aber mit 10 anderen ja schon, von denen 6 abgesagt haben. Ist dann auch kurios, ne?
Ja, aber Ralf Range hätte ich auch über Sini, den sie dann eingeordnet. Tut mir leid, die Bayern-Fans werden wieder sauer, weil ich so gemein bin. Es tut mir ja leid, aber es ist so einfach. Ich kann auch nichts dafür.
Der kann halt Deutsch. Der Rale kann Deutsch.
Ja, aber dann muss der Sini, den sich halt einfach ein bisschen strecken. Also soll er halt, also ich meine, er hatte doch jetzt 3 Jahre Zeit, Deutsch zu lernen, Alexi. Also warum, warum...
Da dachte man halt, Xabi Alonso kann es und er kann Deutsch. Also gebrochen, aber er kann es.
Okay, also Alexi, ich wollte gleich dieser Wunde bohren. Es ist mir nur aufgefallen und sie wird auch nicht mehr zu heilen sein, leider glaube ich, zumindest nicht jetzt in dieser Sendung noch. Wer waren denn dein MVP der Saison, dein Anzang Hero der Saison und der Moment der Saison?
Ich will bei uns an der Euro noch mal kurz erleuchten, was das bedeutet und dann fange ich aber ein mit dem MVP. Ist aber ein Spieler, ich weiß nicht, ob du es mir erlaubst, aber einer, der nur in der Rückrunde da war, denn er war in der Hinterrunde bei Ajax Amsterdam, wo er überhaupt nicht Fuß fassen konnte. Ich rede vom neuen Warrer, nämlich Georges Nicotatze, weiterhin ein geografisches Ausnahmetalent. Er hat als Klügelspieler 14 Treffer und 20 Ligue 1-Spiele erzielt. Er hätte fast Metz gerettet, aber gestern Abend ist Metz ja abgestiegen nach der Relegations-Rückrunden-Partie bei St. Etienne. Aber er ist heiß um Wurben, soll nach Monaco wechseln. Er erinnert mich sehr an den Napolitanen und künftigen PSG-Stars. Nämlich Trickreich, Trickelstark. Er kann die Liga aufmischen. Dann haben wir dann auf dem höchsten Niveau ein georgisches Duel um die Meisterschaft mit PSG und Monaco. Aber Nico Taze hat Metz wieder Leben eingeraucht nach seiner Rückkehr im Winter. Metz wäre fast gerettet ohne dieses Rückspiel gestern Abend. Währenddessen höre ich gerade, dass der 1. Elfstern Nürnberg den Trainer entlassen hat. Ich hab's auch gehört gelesen. Nico Taze, ein unbekanter Name, aber schon einer, der er werden muss. Ich glaube schon, dass ihm die Zukunft gehört und der den gleichen Weggang oder Laufbahn durchstehen kann, wie er war. Er muss nicht immer im Papier sein. Er hat auch keine Super-Saison gespielt. Rein spielerisch, statistisch, was natürlich schon wieder sehr geil ist.
Ich glaube, du hast schon ein bisschen den Anzang Hero auch gemacht. Anzang Hero ist ja quasi die Definition, jemand, der eine sehr gute Leistung gebracht hat, aber nicht so im Rampenlicht steht.
Also für beide dann. Wir nennen unseren Freund aus Brasilien Dante, der jetzt in der Liga verlängert hat. Bei 41 hat es natürlich nicht geklappt. Die Champions League Qualifikation, aber immerhin Europa League, Gruppenphase, 5. Geburt, die beste Liga an Abwehr. Und was auch interessant ist bei Nizza, die haben nur zwei Innenverteidiger im Kader. Die ganze Saison lang. Dante und Ex-Chartier Thodibou. Sollte da einer ausfallen, Dante war einmal gesperrt. Zum Beispiel musste da ein Mittelfeldspieler haben. Die haben keinen dritten oder vierten Innenverteidiger im Kader. Wer macht denn da die Kaderschlange? Ja, Ineos natürlich. Er hat nach wie vor Leistung gebracht. Er hat nur ein Spiel verpasst, gelb gesperrt. Ansonsten 90 Minuten immer auf dem Platz gestanden. Natürlich ist er nicht mehr das Schnellste, aber das Stellungsspiel ist nach wie vor 1a. Er fühlt sich einfach nach wie vor saufid. Deswegen macht er noch ein Jahr weiter. Danach war es das wahrscheinlich.
Fantastisch. Das war ja schon nach dieser Saison in dem Posting, in dem er dann angekündigt hat, dass er ein Jahr weiter macht. Der ganze Text vorher, wenn du die letzten 3 Sätze wegnimmst, war eigentlich, danke für die schöne Zeit, ich höre jetzt auf, ich reite jetzt in den Sonnenuntergang. Und übrigens wollte ich euch sagen, ich bin noch ein Jahr da. Dante, sehr, sehr schön. Kann er dann direkt in die Infinity League wechseln. Alexi, was war dein Moment der Saison?
Ich habe auch schon erwähnt, zum Anfang der Sendung, nämlich diese spektakulären Spiele mit Brest. Und natürlich das Spiel des Jahres war, das Bretagne der Brest-Rennen, oder Rennen Brest, ein Stand 4 zu 5. Nicht nur, weil 9 Tore gefallen sind, sondern weil einfach wieder der Underdog beim großen Nachbarn gewonnen hat. Wo es nicht viel erwarten haben, weil es auch eine Phase war, wo Brest geschwäßelt hatte, vor allem körperlich. Und auch psychisch hat man gemerkt, vielleicht wird es noch nichts mit dem Podium für Brest. Vor allem die Spiele davor. Brest war oft in Führung und vorne. Und dann hatte er immer wieder Tore kassiert. Am Spielende, also nicht die viertelste Mannschaft der Liga. Aber die haben sich zusammengerappelt gegen Rennes. Das war entscheidend für die letzten fünf, sechs Spiele, dass man gezeigt hat, man will diese historische Saison noch einmal bestätigen. Wir wollen, wenn es geht, es weiter. Aber auch bitter, dann bis zu qualifizieren für die Champions League. Das hat dann am letzten Spieltag gereicht. Währenddessen Rennes, der große Nachbar, der am Saisonstart als einer der Hauptkonkurrenten für Peugeot galt, weil man sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen hatte, weil man mit François Pinot, einer der zwei, drei reichsten französischen Unternehmer hat als Eigentümer, der aber undieren Geld ausgibt für Rennes, hatte man schon gedacht, dass Rennes mindestens unter den ersten drei kommt. Am Ende war Rennes, glaube ich, neun oder zehnter, spielt gar kein Europa-Bokal in nächster Saison. Und das ist vielleicht mit oder mit nicht die größte Enttäuschung der Saison. Deswegen war dieses Spiel Rennes Rest für mich das Spiel des Jahres. Auf der einen Seite ein tiefer Absturz eines wichtigen Großen, auf der anderen Seite die Bestätigung einer Sensation, die wahrscheinlich eine einjährige Sensation bleiben wird.
Aber wirklich, ich glaube, das war damals noch ein Match to Watch, das hatte David mitgebracht. Das war To Watch, ja. Und dann gucke ich nach 20 Minuten so in den Livescoring und sehe, ah, steht schon 2-1. Und dann ging es eben bis zum 4-9. Also allein nach neun Minuten stand schon 2-0 für Rennes. Sehr schön. Alexi, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank dir. Auch danke, dass du dir jetzt nochmal die Zeit genommen hast. Weiß ich wirklich sehr zu schätzen. Du kannst hier einfach auflegen und dann hören wir dich hoffentlich in der nächsten Saison wieder. Die gibt's off-record vom Vorstand. Aber die wollen wir haben, Alexi. Dafür haben wir ja noch andere Kanäle.
Aber es geht um Mohamed Zidane, nicht nur Zinedine Zidane.
Erzähl uns doch einfach die Geschichte zu Mohamed Zidane. Bis hoffentlich bald mal wieder.
Tschau, Alex.
Ja, und wir machen noch weiter mit euren Awards, würde ich sagen. Alex, magst du mal weitermachen? Wer ist denn dein MVP der Saison geworden?
Ich muss dazu aber ausholen bei meinen Awards generell. Vor allem beim Thema MVP. Man würde es natürlich denken, wenn jemand so souverän die Meisterschaft gewinnt, ist es obvious, dann nehme ich einen von den Großkopferten von Real Madrid. Da gibt es ja den einen oder anderen schillernden Star. Man muss aber dazu erzählen, also der eine ist Obvious Bellingham. Der war aber nur in der Hinrunde für mich auf MVP-Level. Da hat er ja, ich glaube, die Torjägerkanone angeführt oder die Torjägerliste, sorry, hat sehr viele wichtige Tore geschossen, sehr viele späte Tore, also wirklich brutaler Start in die Real Madrid-Karriere. Aber das ist komplett abgeflaut in der Rückrunde und ein bisschen stellvertretend dafür. Wir haben jetzt heute nicht über das Champions League-Finale gesprochen, aus guten Gründen. Aber die Leistung im Champions League-Finale ist so ein bisschen stellvertretend, finde ich, für die komplette Rückrunde. Da war er nicht mehr so präsent, nicht mehr so ausschlaggebend. Deswegen fällt es mir schwer, ihn als MVP zu wählen, auch wenn er vielleicht ein bisschen eine stellvertretende Choice wäre für Real Madrid. Vinicius Junior war wahrscheinlich im Champions League-Finale oder auf die Champions League gesehen vielleicht einer der größten Stars von Real Madrid, hat aber nur fünf Assists gegeben in der Saison. Ist ein bisschen dürftig, muss man echt sagen. Also ist natürlich ein Gamechanger, aber da erwarte ich mir auch, Output. Und Real Madrid ist ja nicht Meister geworden aufgrund der Leistung von nur Vinicius oder von Bellingham, sondern sie waren ja wirklich die dominanteste Mannschaft mit Kroos im Mittelfeld, der wie immer die Fäden zieht, mit Juameini, mit hinten die Abwehr, Rüdiger, brutal. Also das waren wirklich ein paar Säulen, die sie zur besten Mannschaft gemacht haben. Und da gibt es nicht diesen einen Star, der raussticht. Deswegen nehme ich keinen Real Madrid-Spieler. Einen Baser-Spieler kannst du nicht nehmen, weil die haben mich zu sehr enttäuscht. Und deswegen nehme ich den Torschützenkönig Dovbik von Girona. Weil da sind wir beim Thema Stellvertretend für die Shooting-Star-Mannschaft dieser Saison, die Girona einfach ist. Den Torschützenkönig zu nehmen, glaube ich, ist keine falsche Choice. Von daher würde ich auf Dovbik gehen.
Ja, und du musst dir Toni Kroos noch als Anzang Hero aufheben. Ganz genau, ey? Woher weißt du das? Weil ich weiß einfach, wie du tickst.
Nein, ich nehme ihn nicht als Anzang Hero, weil er zu sehr besangen wurde.
Man muss ja sagen, ihm persönlich ist das ja sehr zu gönnen. Und die Bilanz ist ja auch heftig. Aber naja, gut, es gibt keine Aber. Ihm ist das sehr zu gönnen. Christian, magst du deinen MWP?
Ich muss kurz mal noch etwas einfangen, was ich vorhin angesprochen habe. Antonio Conte ist noch nicht mein MWP. Aber ich habe hier vorhin erklärt, woher er kommt, nämlich aus Sao Puglien und habe Bari genannt. Aber Antonio Conte kommt aus Lecce. Und Bari und Lecce sind sehr rivalisierend. Deswegen, falls Antonio Conte uns zuhört, müssen wir das gleich wieder einfangen. Bari ist die Hauptstadt, aber er ist aus Lecce. Das wäre ihm sehr wichtig. Er ist aber immer noch im Süden Italiens. Dementsprechend passt das zu Napoli. MVP. Ich habe mir auch viele Gedanken gemacht. Wie Alex schon angesprochen, da gibt es oft viele Varianten. Wir haben aber noch gar nicht über Inter gesprochen. Man muss nach dieser Saison schon über Inter sprechen. Bei Inter ist es ähnlich, wie Alex gerade bei Real es schon thematisiert hat. Ich finde auch nicht, dass es den einen gibt, der raussticht. Da könnte man jetzt mehrere nennen. Angefangen mit Lautaro als Tor-Schützenkönig. Gar keine Frage. Aber ich habe mich jetzt schon für Cialanolo entschieden. Weil Cialanolo wirklich nochmal das fortgeführt hat, was er in der letzten Saison schon gestartet hat. Er ist letztes Jahr schon auf diese 6er-Position gewechselt. Da war ein großer Faktor, dass Inter ins Champions League-Finale gekommen ist, wo sie zwar verloren haben, aber eine sehr gute Figur gegen City abgegeben haben. Dieses Jahr hat er das einfach nochmal fortgeführt. Er war für mich einer mit Abstand der konstantesten Spieler. Du hast das Gefühl, viele werden vielleicht noch die Hakan Cialanolo von früheren Erinnerungen haben. Ich glaube nicht, dass sehr viele daran gedacht haben, dass er mal so eine zentrale Rolle im wahrsten Sinn des Wortes im Herzen einer Mannschaft, einer großen europäischen Mannschaft einnehmen kann. Er hat einfach diese Weiterentwicklung fortgeführt. Extrem verlässlich eben, wirklich immer. Gerade die Liga-Saison, du hast von Cialanolo immer bekommen, diesen neuen Cialanolo, diesen gegen den Ball so unfassbar, laufstarke, aggressive. Also wirklich, er ist ein Regisseur geworden, im besten Sinne des Wortes. Da würde ich Barella und Mikitarin auch dazu nehmen. Das sind seine Sidekicks einfach. Also wirklich dieses zentrale Mittelfeld unter Sagi. Das ist nicht nur Cialanolo allein. Gerade Mikitarin, den könnte man da auch mit reinnehmen, weil er wahnsinnig viel abgesichert hat. Das Zusammenspiel dieser drei, wunderbar. Aber Cialanolo halt einfach als Symbolfigur. Und dazu noch, muss ich sagen, glaube ich, für mich mittlerweile der sicherste Elfmeterschütze. Also Cialanolo vom Punkt. Er hatte diese Saison eben, am Ende waren es 13 Saison-Tore. Zehn davon waren Elfmeter. Ich habe jetzt nicht mehr die genaue Zahl, aber ich glaube seine letzten, ja ich will jetzt nichts sagen, aber Ewigkeiten keine Elfmeter mehr verschossen. Und wirklich, also Cialanolo vom Punkt. Wirklich eine Bank durch und durch. Und wie gesagt, einfach auch ein Symbol dieser, ja dieser Inter-Weiterentwicklung, die sie unter Insagi genommen haben. Wir hatten sie auch schon hier logisch diese Saison angesprochen. Insagi finde ich, deswegen will ich auch Insagi so ein bisschen damit reinnehmen. Insagi hat wirklich diese Mannschaft, ja auf ein spielerisch neues Niveau gehoben. Und du hast sie angesprochen, vorhin die Dominanz in der Serie A, also wirklich beeindruckend. Das einzige Bittere, da wäre in der Champions League ich bleibe dabei, für Inter wäre diese Saison sehr, sehr viel bis alles möglich gewesen. Dieses Rückspiel gegen Atletico, das ist logischerweise der Makel. Aber was heißt das Rückspiel, das Hinspiel eigentlich auch schon, weil sie da viel mehr Tore machen müssen und dann wird es im Rückspiel vielleicht gar nicht mehr eng. Aber logisch, was Inter einfach in der Liga dieses Jahr dominiert und gerissen hat, war auch von der spielerischen Weiterentwicklung her sehr beeindruckend.
Aber wirklich sehr schön. Also Hakan Salahnulu stellvertretend für im Grunde alle. Nein, Inter, die meisten davon hast du jetzt auch genannt. Alex, wer ist dein Unsung Hero?
Ich muss einen Namen nennen, der heute schon gefallen ist. Das ist Trainer Michel von Girona. Das hat einen guten Grund, weil ich das Gefühl habe, der wird wirklich nicht besungen. Findet medial auch nicht so statt, bekommt nicht die Recognition, die er verdient hat. Auch ich habe natürlich viel Girona gelobt, welchen tollen Fußball sie spielen. Savio genannt, Dovbügg genannt, Alex Garcia genannt. Aber wer macht diese Mannschaft zu der Mannschaft? Diese ist der Trainer natürlich. Du hast ja wirklich das Gefühl, der bekommt nicht die Anerkennung auch nicht nur medial, sondern wahrscheinlich auch in der Branche. Wenn du überlegst, wie viele Vereine neue Trainer suchten und fanden und irgendwie war er nie im Rennen, wurde nie auch nur genannt. Vincent Companis ist abgestiegen mit Burnley. Davor natürlich grandiose Zweitligasaison, aber abgestiegen, zack landet bei Bayern. Liverpool hatte eine Vakanz, hat sich für einen anderen Trainer entschieden. Auch da war er nicht mal irgendwie im Rennen. Also, dass er nicht mal genannt wird, fand ich so bemerkenswert. Deswegen passt dieses Ansang für mich sehr. De Zerbi wird ja sehr besungen weltweit. Was wurde der mit Brighton? oder der 9. Der andere führt eine Mannschaft aus der 2. Liga in die Champions League. Und irgendwie schwemmt man natürlich viel vom Fußball der Mannschaft und erstmals in der Champions League ever. Aber der Trainer bekommt irgendwie nicht den Credit, den er verdient. Deswegen ist Michel mein Ansanghero, damit er mal besungen wird. Der gute Mann.
Eine sogar noch bessere Wahl als Toni Kroos, ich gebe es dir zu.
Er macht halt einfach tolle Arbeit. Und deswegen soll das mal Anerkennung finden. Ja, City Group steckt dahinter, mathematisiert, aber aus der 2. Liga, erstmals ever nach Europa und dann in die Champions League hoch verdient, mit tollem Fußball, mit 86 Saisontoren zu führen. Barca zweimal geschlagen, unter anderem. Das ist mehr als erwähnenswert. Und das ist eine tolle Arbeit vom Trainer des Jahres in Spanien, wie ich finde. Und deswegen ist mein Sunghero hier mal.
Ja, da freue ich mich sehr, wenn wir das dann in der Champions League mal sehen können. Also ich freue mich total auf Bologna, auch wenn es ein bisschen bitter ist, dass wir da Trainerwechsel haben.
Ja, das ist genau so eine Sache. Wir haben es jetzt vorhin nicht ganz angesprochen, weil Bologna, glaube ich, noch in keiner Kategorie stattfand. Aber das ist das Bittere, dass die direkt, Motta, auch noch ein Juwe verlieren. Das hat ja auch immer ein Geschmäckle so ein bisschen. Find ich sehr, sehr schade bei Bologna. Deswegen eigentlich ja gar nicht schlecht oder gar nicht so schlimm, dass Michel wahrscheinlich nirgends gehandelt wird und dementsprechend bleiben wird. Aber ja, verdient für mich einfach mehr Recognition.
Und deswegen, tolle Arbeit. Christian, wer ist dein Anzug hier?
Schauen wir mal, ich muss, unabgesprochen mit Alex bei mir, ich bleibe auch in der Trainerie, gewollt jetzt auch. Mir tut es echt auch leid, dass jetzt Bologna nicht nochmal thematisiert wurde. Wäre es völlig wert gewesen. Deswegen auch hier nochmal Thiago Motta wäre logisch auch ein perfekter Kandidat für einen MVP gewesen. Müssen wir gar nicht groß drum rum reden. Aber vielleicht nochmal reinhören, wir haben ja schon zwei, drei Jahre darüber gesprochen. Aber nur um das auch nochmal zu sagen, die hätten sich mehr als verdient, auch gar keine Frage. Aber ich bleibe auch im Trainersektor. Und jetzt hatten wir eben, wir hatten Gasperini, wir hatten Insagi, wir haben Thiago Motta. Einen, der logischerweise nicht so groß thematisiert wurde, war der Trainer von Hellas Verona, Marco Baroni. Und das ist wirklich eine spezielle Geschichte. Also Hellas hat sich gerettet, was an sich schon eine große Aufgabe ist, weil logisch Verona einer der Kandidaten einfach von Anfang an war. Die werden gegen den Abstieg spielen. Marco Baroni, fangen wir kurz an, kam aus Lecce. Da hat Lecce vor zwei Jahren in die Serie A geführt, hat sie dann im ersten Jahr gerettet, was auch die große Aufgabe logischerweise war, weil es für jemand wie Lecce auch nur darum geht, die Klasse zu halten. Kommt dann zu Verona, macht das von Anfang an gut, ist da, wo Hellas sein soll. Und dann passiert was im Winter, es wird manchmal so darüber gesprochen, ja, die halbe Mannschaft ist weggekommen. Und das war wirklich bei Hellas im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes da. Die haben dem im Winter nicht nur sechs Stammspieler, sondern kann sagen, mit die sechs wichtigsten verkauft, bei einem Abstiegskandidaten.
Und warum?
Ja, bei Hellas logischerweise, da ging es dann auch darum, ein bisschen die Kassen zu füllen. Einer dieser Namens, zum Beispiel, Schleswig der Kreis zu Atalanta, Isak Hjern, der schwedische Innenverteidiger, der das jetzt mehr als gut gemacht hat gegen Liverpool, gegen Leverkusen, hinten der zentrale Mann in der Dreierkette. Das war einer, den haben sie, glaube ich, für knapp 10 Millionen verkauft. Dann ist ein Gonsch, der bei Napoli gelandet ist, der war ganz wichtig für die, hat Tore gemacht, Duric, der Mittelstürmer. Also wirklich, Terracciano, absoluter Stammspieler, Farone, Kapitän. Dem ist die Mannschaft weggebrochen, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und trotzdem hat er die drin gehalten. Wenn wir uns anschauen, wie knapp das da hinten war, Abstiegskampf, kommen wir eher auch noch dazu in der letzten Kategorie. Aber das ist wirklich eine große Leistung, weil überraschenderweise, sie haben ihn zwar viel verkauft, aber er hat nicht wirklich viel bekommen im Winter. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass dieses Geld reinvestiert geworden wäre. Und deswegen finde ich das einfach wirklich bemerkenswert, dass eine Mannschaft, einen Trainer, die eh schon hinten drin steckt, wenn ihr da im Winter, nochmal, das waren nicht nur sechs Stammspiele, das waren sechs Säulen wegbrechen, dann trotzdem die Klasse zu halten. Am Ende ist er sogar Dreizentern geworden. Klar, er ist ganz eng da hinten, hat einen Spieltag vor Schluss schon eingetütet. Den Klassenerhalt musste nicht mehr in diese extrem, wie soll man sagen, spannende Konstellation am letzten Spieltag. Und hat jetzt auch verkündet, dass er Hellas verlassen wird. Und ist jetzt einer der Namen, denn, wie Alex ja schon gesagt hat, speziell in Italien ist das Trainer-Karussell diese Saison unfassbar im Sommer. Nur ein Ding dazu, von den ersten zehn werden acht neue Trainer haben. Also nur Gasparini bei Atalanta und Insagi bei Inter. Wenn wir jetzt die zwei Römer mit dazu sehen, die eben in den letzten Wochen und Monaten schon gewechselt haben. Bloß bei Lazio ist noch ein Fragezeichen, ob Tudo bleiben wird, aber egal. Also von den Top Ten werden acht oder neun Trainer haben und dementsprechend werden viele Posten frei. Und Baroni ist jetzt klar nicht im obersten Regal, wird er gehandelt, aber wird zum Beispiel bei Torino gehandelt, er wird bei Monza gehandelt. Also Baroni einer, der auch immer im Hintergrund, gar keiner, der das Mediale oder das Scheinwerferlicht sucht, aber der wirklich, finde ich, in diesen Saison eine herausragende Leistung gezeigt hat, um Hellas unter diesen Umständen in der Liga zu halten.
Und bei Weitem bessere Rückrunde als Hinrunde. Also ohne die Säulen.
Also es ist wirklich schwer zu erklären. Also wirklich großartig, ja.
Sehr, sehr schöne Wahl für den Anzang Hero. Dann ist es besonders undankbar, ist die Kategorie Moment der Saison. Weil wie soll man schon eine Saison auf einen Moment runterbrechen? Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es ja so, dass einem trotzdem manchmal eine Sache dann doch noch so im Gedächtnis bleibt. Was ist denn bei dir, Alex, in dieser La-Liga-Saison?
Schwierig, ich fand die La-Liga-Saison etwas underwhelming. Also es war ja am letzten Spieltag zum Beispiel konnte ja gar nichts mehr passieren. Wir hatten keinen spannenden Meisterschaftskampf. Die Absteiger waren wirklich auch, also die Mannschaften, die unten waren, waren auch wirklich alle schwach. Also Cádiz war ja wirklich das spanische erste FC Köln, können keine Tore schießen, versuchen alles, schaffen irgendwie hinten raus zwei Siege, aber es reicht dann doch nicht. Also es war auch nicht so die Spannung und Dramatik, wie man sich das erwarten würde oder hoffen würde, weder oben, ganz oben, noch eine Ecke drunter, also um die Champions League war es hinten raus auch nicht spannend, unten war es nicht spannend. Deswegen, bei mir blieb sportlich nicht so viel hängen, bin ich ehrlich. Zwei Dinge blieben natürlich hängen, die dann ein bisschen wahrscheinlich die Meisterschaft auch so klar gemacht haben. Das war in beiden Klassikos, hat Real Madrid jeweils in der 90. Minute den Siegtreffer erzielt. Es war Bellingham im Hinspiel-Klassiker, in der Hinrunde im Oktober, glaube ich. Und dann endgültig entschieden wurde die Meisterschaft in Bernabeu im April auch wieder spät gewonnen und auch vielleicht ein bisschen glücklich aufgrund der Umstände. Also das waren so zwei ausschlaggebende späte Tore sportlich, aber die kann man schlecht wählen. Der Moment der Saison gehört Toni Kroos, der seine Karriere beendet hat bei Real Madrid, was Toni Kroos ja vorhin genannt. Das ist jetzt seine Kategorie, denn man muss ihn ja erwähnen. Da geht eine absolute Vereinslegende, eine absolute Ikone. Mit der erfolgreichste Spieler glaube ich der letzten Jahrzehnte. Wobei Modric sammelt ja auch Titel. Also jeder, der bei Real lange war, hat ja viele Titel gesammelt. Ich habe da gar keinen Überblick mehr, wer viele gewonnen hat.
Fünf Spieler, die jetzt zum sechsten Mal die Champions League gewonnen haben.
Das schon, aber ich glaube insgesamt hat er 26 Titel oder so gewonnen, plus minus.
36 glaube ich sogar.
Bei Real meine ich jetzt nicht. Mit Bayern haben wir auch viel gewonnen. Also das ist ein Titelsammler, er ist eine Ikone, ein Erfolgsspieler. Also du kannst ja noch zehn andere Superlative finden. Und deswegen finde ich, Moment der Saison kulminiert sich dann quasi in seinem Abschied im Bernabeu. Ist gebührend, glaube ich, ihn dann hier zumindest in der Kategorie zu nennen. Denn nach wie vor bin ich der Meinung, in Deutschland hat man ihn nicht wertgeschätzt genug. Also nicht nur bei den Bayern als ihn gehen ließen, sondern wirklich auch in den vielen, vielen Jahren danach. In Spanien war er wirklich immer eine Ikone und nicht wegzudenken bei Real Madrid. Und in Deutschland sind solche Spieler, warum auch immer, nicht so, ja, werden nicht so wertgeschätzt.
Warum auch immer, wir wissen es doch, kann man doch sagen. Hier wird halt einfach der Zweikampf höher gewertet als der Pass. Und der Pass wird abgewertet als der Querpass, die er ja auch spielt. Er ist ein horizontaler Ballverteiler.
Aber der macht halt auf Zähne Sinn.
Genau, aber er verliert halt den Ball nicht. Du kannst ihn in jeder Situation anspielen. Und in Spanien ist es halt so, dass Passspiel die Grundlage des Fußballs ist. In Deutschland ist es der Zweikampf. Wie war die Zweikampfquote? Ich mache ja da immer Witze drüber, aber es ist ja Fußballkulturell und es ist ja...
Also es gibt eine schöne Statistik. Ich habe es hier gerade zufällig. Das ist nicht mal am Ende der Saison, sondern das war nach dem Viertelfinale, Halbfinale. Passcompletion, Underpressure, 94,9% Toni Kroos. Ja, in der UEFA Champions League. Also 95% bringt der Underpressure an den Gegner den Ball.
Und dann sagen die Leute, ja, aber es war ja nur ein Querpass. Ja, aber er hat es ja aus dem Druck rausgespielt. Der Gegner musste den Druck dann verschieben, aber egal.
Er führt wirklich die Statistik jedes Jahr in Spanien an, bei der Passcompletion, immer zwischen 92 und 95%. Jedes Jahr ist er da ganz, ganz oben. Also der Mann macht keine Fehler, spielt keine Fehlpässe. Und der ein oder andere tödliche Pass ist ja auch dabei. Und wie gesagt, du hast das schön zusammengefasst. In Spanien wird so ein Spieler wirklich nicht nur wertgeschätzt, sondern dem wird gehuldigt, wenn jemand so Fußball spielt. Und hierzulande ist es nicht der Fall. Und deswegen huldige ich ihm hier auch, indem ich ihm zumindest diese Kategorie gebe in Huldigung seiner grandiosen Karriere.
Und weil wir hier ja die Europa Tour sind, kann ich euch jetzt auch nochmal den Blick aus Italien mitbringen. Und da ist es nämlich genauso wie in Spanien. Also jetzt in den letzten Tagen, seit diese Entscheidung klar war, was Kroos auch bei sehr vielen italienischen Fußball-Experten auch was das hervorgerufen hat, nämlich genau das, immer sein Passspiel wurde mit sehr, sehr großen Namen der Fußballgeschichte auch in Italien verglichen. Also es ist definitiv so, dass die italienische und die spanische Betrachtungsweise des Fußballs, auch wenn es da logischerweise Unterschiede gibt, aber was das Thema betrifft, sind sie sich auch sehr einig. Nämlich eben genau dieses Wort ist sehr gefallen. Es geht halt um den Pass und der Pass ist im Fußball ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr zentrales und wichtiges Element und deswegen hat Toni Kroos wirklich auch in Italien zuletzt echt beeindruckend, was da auch schon vor dem Champions League-Finale also es hat jetzt noch gar nichts damit zu tun, dass das jetzt wieder so geendet ist, wie es geendet ist. Sondern wirklich, da wurde genau das auch hervorgehaben, auch diese, wurde auch seine ruhige Art und so sehr, sehr gut angekommen. Also, ja, wie gesagt, kann ich aus Italien mitgeben, definitiv da auch einen sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr hohen Stellenwert.
Darf ich bei dem Thema den Blick in die Gegenwart und Zukunft richten? Denn Toni Kroos ist der Stichwort. Ich glaube, er wird der deutschen Nationalmannschaft brutal gut zu Gesicht stehen und sie wirklich besser machen und längst überfällig, dass er wieder für Deutschland spielt. Und ich glaube, er wird Deutschland wirklich auf ein neues Level hieven. Also, wenn sie Europameister werden, ist Toni Kroos eine Key-Personalie. Zumindest der, oder der guten EM, die ich erwarte von Deutschland, sage ich, bin ich ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, der wird Deutschland definitiv signifikant besser machen.
Zwei Gedanken dazu. Das eine ist, so wie im Passspiel hat Toni Kroos auch in seiner Karriere eine extrem gute Entscheidungsfindung gehabt. Also, es würde mich enorm interessieren, ob die Entscheidung damals für Real Madrid nicht nur eine war, weil Real dieser Verein ist, sondern weil er ja auch weiß, er wechselt in eine Liga, in der das, was er kann, wertgeschätzt wird. Ich finde es schon interessant, dass er nie in der Premier League gespielt hat. Und ob das jetzt nur Zufall war oder ob da ein Gedanke dahinter steckt, weil ich würde es ihm zutrauen, denn die Entscheidungsfindung auf diese Art und Weise, im eigenen Podcast natürlich, er ist auch Marketing-Chef, muss man auch sagen, aber auch zu diesem Zeitpunkt bekannt zu geben, dass er seine Karriere beendet, das ist ja auch perfekt. Er hört wirklich auf einem absoluten Höhepunkt auf. Er kommuniziert es zu dem Zeitpunkt, der weit genug weg ist vom Finale, aber knapp genug am letzten Saisonsspiel, dass er jetzt auch nicht 150.000 Medienanfragen beantworten muss. Die Fans können ihn aber noch feiern. Also ich glaube, auch dieser Abschied ist eben sehr gut gewählt. Das finde ich interessant. Also das ist der eine Gedanke, die Entscheidungsfindung unter Zweite. Der knüpft eben an das an, was du jetzt gerade sagst, Alex. Ich habe da nämlich auch darüber nachgedacht, warum auch im Nationalteam Toni Kroos nicht ganz so geschätzt würde. Und da fallen einem ja zum Beispiel auch Negativbeispiele ein. Also dieser verunglückte Rückpass im WM-Finale 2014, wo eigentlich das 0 zu 1 fallen muss, aber es fällt nicht. Higuain steht alleine vorne, schiebt den Ball einfach dran vorbei. Und dann habe ich mich auch gewundert und dachte mir, sehr interessant, dass mir diese Szene zuerst einfällt. Dann habe ich versucht, mich an gute Szenen im Finale zu erinnern. Und dann ist mir auch aufgefallen, das Finale war ja auch kein so gutes Spiel von ihm. Und der Gedanke, der aber glaube ich dann auch den Blick auf die EM, was könnte jetzt anders sein, hin abrundet ist, ich glaube, Toni Kroos wurde im deutschen Nationalteam nie so eingebunden, wie es seine Stärke ist. Er war nicht derjenige, zu dem immer der Ball kam und er hat dann entschieden, auf welche Spielfeldseite und so weiter er jetzt geht, sondern er musste fast darum betteln, auch mal im Zentrum heraus den Ball zu bekommen, weil der Spielaufbau ging immer so viel über die Außenverteidiger. Und das könnte jetzt unter Nagelsmann tatsächlich anders werden. Nagelsmann hat dafür extrem wenig Zeit, aber er möchte diesen anderen Aufbau. Dann könnte Toni Kroos tatsächlich auch in einem möglichen Viertelfinale, Halbfinale oder sogar Finale. Dann könnte er da vielleicht sogar Toni Kroos brillieren, so wie wir es auch bei Real gesehen haben. Wenn die Nationalmannschaft aber so weiterspielt, wie sie vor Nagelsmann gespielt hat und letztlich auch vor den letzten Spielen von Nagelsmann, dann glaube ich, wird es eher wieder so sein, dass wir zwar alle wissen, Toni Kroos ist ein guter Spieler, aber dann wird das Narrativ vielleicht eher sein, im Nationalteam hat er es nicht gezeigt oder in den großen Spielen versagt. Was natürlich totaler Quatsch wäre, weil er in so vielen großen Spielen perfekt gespielt hat bei Real. Aber ich glaube, die Art und Weise, wie Deutschland als Nationalteam Fußball gespielt hat, das kam Toni Kroos nie entgegen und deswegen war es da leichter für ihn in Anführungszeichen unterzutauchen oder übersehen zu werden. Das sind quasi zwei Seiten einer Medaille, glaube ich. Und vielleicht deswegen auch, ich glaube auch, seine Entscheidung damals zurückzutreten, war auch eben richtig. Weil es konnte sich ein Uli Hoeneß, sorry, dass ich jetzt mit Uli Hoeneß komme, aber in dem Fall ist es jetzt wirklich, finde ich, auch nicht an den Haaren herbeigezogen, der konnte sich damals in eine der größten Fußball-Talkshows setzen und könnte sagen, Toni Kroos hat in diesem Fußball nichts mehr verloren und er wurde nicht verbal von allen anderen dafür attackiert, sondern die saßen alle da und haben gesagt, ja, ja, ja, war wirklich schlecht gegen England. Und wenn du das siehst, dann ist es auch eine sehr gute Entscheidung vielleicht zu sagen, wißt du was, ich mache hier weiter mit Real und bin sehr gespannt.
Ein Ding noch vielleicht ganz kurz, für mich, wir haben ja heute auch darüber gesprochen, in verschiedenen Aspekten auf dieses höchste Niveau eben. Und ich finde, Kroos steht für mich halt einfach für absolute Konstanz. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es bei Real, ich habe logisch nicht so viel, all diese Realspiele gesehen, aber ich kann mich an kein schlechtes Spiel von Toni Kroos erinnern, wenn es darauf ankam und es waren sehr viele. Und deswegen diese auf dem höchsten Level, diese Konstanz dann auch über Jahre, Jahre zu bringen, in so einer zentralen Position, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zentral, das finde ich, zeigt halt bei Leistungssportlern, wenn du das halt auch schaffst, über so eine lange Zeit. Also ich finde, Konstanz ist ja manchmal, finde ich mal, so ein Wort, das vielleicht gar nicht so positiv besetzt ist, aber ich finde, in dem Zusammenhang ist es bei Kroos für mich halt auch so ein Aspekt dieser Karriere quasi.
Also nur mal einmal abschließend noch. Einmal Weltmeister, sechsmal die Champions League gewonnen, dreimal Deutscher Meister, viermal Spanischer Meister, fünfmal den UEFA Super Cup gewonnen, dreimal Deutscher Pokalsieger, einmal nur Spanischer Pokalsieger. Was war da eigentlich los? Und viermal Spanischer Super Pokal. Okay, gut, das ist jetzt dann der falsche Super Pokal, den ich hier, der Super Cup.
Und Weltcup-Sieger, Weltpokal.
Dann war das fünfmal, ne? Sechsmal die Club-WM mit Bayern auch noch. Ehrlicherweise, ich hab schon versucht hier die nicht ganz so wichtigen Mittelfelder wegzulassen, es ist mir nicht komplett gelungen.
Also wenn das nicht konstant ist, ne? Konstanter Titel, Hamster. Konstant die Geschicke, die Fäden gezogen im Mittelfeld. Und nochmal, Blick voraus, ich glaub Deutschland wird eine sehr gute EM spielen und da wird Toni Kroos auch großen Anteil dran haben. Und er bringt Konstanze in die Mannschaft, die glaube ich diese Mannschaft dringend gebrauchen konnte, zuletzt schon unter Hansi Flick nicht hatte. Und jetzt glaube ich, haben wird.
Absolutes Traumtribügenspräch, mit Toni Kroos mal über ein paar wichtige Spiele in seiner Karriere zu sprechen. Weil es muss so sein, so wie er Fußball spielt, muss er auch sehr gut über Fußball nachdenken und vielleicht auch sprechen können. Ehrlich gesagt, ich höre einfach mal luppend, ich habe keine Zeit dafür und denke mir so, naja, bei dem Podcast ist es wirklich so, wenn etwas Wichtiges passiert, dann kriege ich es über Sekundärberichterstattung mit. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie viel man das da schon hört. Aber ich könnte mir forsten, dass man richtig, richtig interessante Gespräche über Fußball mit ihm führen kann. Aber an den kommt man natürlich nicht mehr ran.
Ne, der hört ja jetzt auf im Sommer, hat er ja mehr Zeit.
Ja, aber das wird alles immer nur 40 Minuten und das Management hört mit usw. Und dann wird das, also das habe ich ja nun wirklich die Erfahrung schon gemacht, auch mit aktiven oder ehemaligen aktiven Fußballern im Rasenfunk. Die erste dreiviertel Stunde brauchst du erst mal, dass die merken, ach so, ich kann hier erzählen. Und dann erinnern sie sich langsam und dann fangen sie an zu erzählen. Das heißt, genau dann, wenn das Management von Toni Kroos sagen würde, so danke, das war's, ihr seid schon 10 Minuten drüber, würde es eigentlich losgehen. Deswegen, das ist, naja. So, Toni Kroos, sehr schön. Ich glaube, da wird auch Titel dieser Folge. Das hat er verdient. Und dann brauchen wir jetzt aber noch den Moment der Saison in der Serie A.
Ja, ähm, auch sehr schwierig, sehr viele. Aber ich möchte nochmal über den Moment der Saison auf den Abstiegskampf eben mit reingehen. Denn anders als bei Alex in Spanien, war es in Italien äußerst emotional am Ende. Vielleicht gar kurz da die Klammer. Empoli hat sich durch ein Tor in der Nachspielzeit gerettet gegen die Roma. Frosinone dadurch abgestiegen. Frosinone hatte das Direkturial gegen Udinese am letzten Spieltag zu Hause. Sie hätte 2 Resultate von 3 gehabt, Siege oder Unentschieden. Sie hat 0-1 knapp verloren, auch weil Udinese, Torhüter 2, 3 brutale Dinge rausgeholt hat. Wie es dazu gekommen ist, hat eben auch ein Teil meines Moments, nämlich der Abstiegskampf. Wir sehen es an der Tabelle. Hellas als 13. hatte 38 Punkte und Frosinone als 18. 35 Punkte. Es waren sehr viele Mannschaften involviert. Es gab ein sehr beeindruckendes 4-3 von Kaljeri gegen Frosinone. Darüber hatten wir damals auch gesprochen. Das Besondere daran war, dass Kaljeri bis zur 72. Minute 0-3 zurück lag. Sie hat das Spiel noch gedreht durch zwei Tore in der Nachspielzeit. Also nicht nur den Ausgleich gemacht, sondern das 4-3. Ich weiß, am Ende kann man sich immer 100 Momente raussuchen. Aber wenn wir uns die Tabelle anschauen, hat Kaljeri am Ende der Saison einen Punkt mehr als Frosinone. Frosinone hatte es im letzten Spiel noch selbst in der Hand. Es war wirklich ein sehr emotionaler Abstiegskampf. Deswegen dieses 1-4-3, ähnlich wie bei Brests Spiel von Alexis, das war an sich schon sehr spektakulär. 0-3 nach 72 Minuten noch drehen. Aber es hatte jetzt wirklich am Ende eine große Auswirkung auf diesen sehr spannenden Abstiegskampf.
Ich hätte jetzt gewettet, du nimmst Ranieri. Ja, aber das hängt ja quasi damit zusammen.
Dann hätte er ja nur Trainer besprochen heute. Ja, ich wollte sagen, das ist ja was Sportliches.
Eine eigene Trainer-Sendung, genau. Hätte man da nehmen können, absolut, definitiv. Merken wir an so einer Saisonrückblick, dass es da noch sehr, sehr viele andere Geschichten gegeben hätte.
Das ist die Leerstelle, die immer bleibt, auch hier im Rasenfunk. Deswegen der Hinweis, es gibt ja auch weitere Podcasts. Ich habe schon Click and Rush, habe ich vorhin, Serie Amore könnte natürlich hören. Und den Tiki-Taki, Tiki-Taka, der Liga-Podcast. Als Deutscher muss ich mich damit nicht auskennen. Mich interessieren nur Zweikampfquoten und haben sie geblutet. Für mich sind Füße geblutet, ist die einzige Frage, die ich mir stelle. Da bin ich ganz wie Mario Basler. Alex, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Stellvertretend natürlich für die ganze La Liga-Fraktion. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Sehr gerne.
Und herzlichen Dank, Christian Bernhardt, stellvertretend für die Serie A-Fraktion. Danke dir.
Ich sage auch vielen Dank.
Und wir danken natürlich Alexi Menüsch und allen Ligue 1-Experten, die in dieser Saison zu Wort gekommen sind. Und jetzt geht es hier etwas überraschend gleich noch weiter. Unverhofft kommt oft, Uli Hebel hat es doch noch geschafft, hier zu sein. Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich hätte fast gesagt, guten Morgen, aber das wäre gelogen.
Es wäre mal ein Morgen gewesen. Schön, dass wir jetzt auch über die Premier League sprechen können, auch wenn es natürlich für dich genauso schwierig ist, wie für die anderen, sich zwei Themen da herauszupicken. Aber was würdest du denn sagen, ist mit Blick auf die Abschlusstabelle vielleicht eine der wichtigsten Geschichten dieser Premier League Saison?
Das Offensichtliche, aber das haben wir glaube ich zu oft unterwegs in der Liga Tour besprochen, wäre Aston Villa, die glaube ich die große Überraschung darstellen und es geschafft haben, endlich mal ein Team in die Top 6 zu spülen. Das ist jetzt nicht immer da gewesen ist, aber da wir es zu oft besprochen haben, versuche ich mich im Generellen und sage mal, es gab ein Meisterschaftsrennen, das es so nicht gab in den letzten Jahren und das auf eine Weise irgendwie überraschend war, aber vor allen Dingen an der Spitze einen Zweikampf zum zweiten Mal in Folge heraufbeschwornert, der mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit die Zukunft sein wird in der Premier League, zumindest die nahe Zukunft, weil wir sind ja durch Jürgen Klopp erinnert worden daran, dass alles ein Ende haben kann. Und irgendwann wird auch Pep Guardiola's Zeit bei Manchester City zu Ende gehen, wahrscheinlich am Ende der kommenden Saison sogar, so wie die Dinge aussehen im Moment. Und dann ist dieser Kampf natürlich fürs erste auch hinterfragt, aber ich finde es schon stark, dass Arsenal so lange dabei war, wirklich aus dieser Nichtmeisterschaftssaison Nummer 1 gelernt zu haben, scheint bis zum Schluss wirklich City alles abverlangt haben. Und vierte Meisterschaft in Folge gab es so auch noch nicht. Das ist das Langweiligste aller Themen, das weiß ich, aber es ist schon total bemerkenswert, finde ich, dass dieser Roboter da vorne dran geht in England und dass es aber jetzt ein Team gibt, das offensichtlich keine Fehlertoleranz zulässt. Und, und das haben die wenigsten auf dem Schirm gehabt, ich habe es glaube ich schon hier auch gesagt, dass ich denke, wenn alle Dinge optimal laufen, dann sind sie bis zum Schluss dabei. Jetzt waren sie bis zur vorvorletzten Runde dabei, also nicht bis ganz zum Schluss aus eigenem Verschulden heraus, aber auf Liverpool ist wieder da oder war wieder da, ist jetzt die Frage, ob sie es bleiben sozusagen. Das ist ja dann auch noch ein Moment, den man als Deutscher vertraglich verpflichtet zu bringen hat, wenn es um Premier League geht in dieser Saison, dass da ja die Ära auf jeden Fall auch zu Ende geht in Liverpool.
Ja, es ist ja auch wirklich leider ein bisschen unterbelichtet gewesen hier, einfach weil es terminlich immer nicht hingehauen hat mit der Premier League. Wenn du jetzt mal so, also dann lass mal über das Meisterschaftsrennen nochmal sprechen und mit Liverpool eben beginnen. Wenn du jetzt nochmal mit ein bisschen Abstand auf diese Phase zurückblickst, in der Liverpool im Grunde seine komplette Saison weggeworfen hat. Woran glaubst du lag das?
Oh, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich glaube, dass am Ende, also das muss fast so sein, dass die Körner ausgegangen sind. Alles andere wäre komisch, weil sie haben im Dezember, im Januar, hatten sie zwischenzeitlich eine halbe Mannschaft nicht mit dabei. Wie im Übrigen alle in der Saison in der Premier League. Das ist epidemisch, was verletzungsbedingt passiert ist überall. Das habe ich auch nochmal nachgeschaut. Es ist tatsächlich zahlenmäßig so, dass die separaten Verletzungen als auch die Fehltage insgesamt mit Abstand die höchsten sind in den letzten Jahren. Das ist nicht nur ein Gefühl gewesen, sondern es ist so. Liverpool war davon vor allen Dingen im Dezember, im Januar extrem betroffen. Sie haben das komischerweise fehlerlos durchgezogen. Also in der Phase, als alle dachten, na gut, jetzt werden sie auf jeden Fall verlieren, haben sie es nicht gemacht, seltsamerweise. Und als man dann dachte, okay, jetzt haben sie wieder alle an Bord, da wirkten sie auch mitunter ein bisschen müde zum Schluss. Und ich würde tippen, dass das eine Müdigkeit sein muss. Wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr körperlicher Natur, sondern vor allen Dingen mentaler Natur, weil sie waren ja in allen Wettbewerben lange dabei, haben aber dann am Ende gegen Bergamo verloren und irgendwie damit ging es los. Das war diese eine Woche. Als sie so. Wir haben so hoch verloren gegen Bergamo, das hat ja hier in Deutschland alle gewundert. Das war's, Bergamo. Also bis zum Schluss komischerweise. Und irgendwie hab ich da das Gefühl, dass sie da gemerkt haben, okay, die anderen machen auch keine Fehler, das macht dann glaube ich die mentale Ermüdung noch mal zusätzlich schwieriger, wenn du halt weißt, die sind halt wirklich, die machen gar nichts mehr falsch. Das macht es dann wahrscheinlich auch noch mal schwieriger. Ich fürchte, das ist ein weicher Faktor, weil ich nichts Strukturelles erkennen konnte oder so.
Also das ging ja quasi los mit dem 2 zu 2 gegen United, dann eben gegen Bergamo zu Hause verloren, dann gegen Crystal Palace zu Hause verloren und damit waren im Grunde schon die Punkte weg. Also jetzt am Ende waren es ja noch ein paar mehr, die dann gefehlt haben, aber so ging das dahin. Und wenn wir dann auf Arsenal blicken, auch Arsenal hat ja dann in einer Saisonphase letztlich diese Saison weggeschmissen, aber das ist jetzt immer weggeschmissen, ist ein hartes Wort für auf sehr hohem Niveau sich bewegen. Das will ich hier nochmal klarstellen. Was waren da dann die Gründe? Müssen wir da dann auch auf Verletzungen gucken? Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, es werden auch weiche Faktoren sein.
Ich weiß, das ist so das Narrativ, dass die was weggeschmissen haben. Also wenn wir jetzt mal von der Champions League sprechen, und das machen wir nur kurz, was soll einem die Premier League vor allen Dingen gehen, dann war es sicherlich die Jugendlichkeit, die Nicht-Erfahrenheit sozusagen und glaube ich, das leichte Knie schlottern auf dem Niveau, was im Übrigen völlig in Ordnung ist, ganz normal. In der Liga ist vor allen Dingen am Ende wahrscheinlich das Eston-Villa-Spiel das Entscheidende gewesen, weil in der Phase haben sie alle keine Fehler mehr gemacht, die Citys und die Arsenals, bis auf eben diesen einen Fehler, der aber gegen dieses Team in der Art und Weise passieren kann. Den gleichen Fehler hat City auch gemacht, nur halt am Nikolaustag. Und dann ist er nicht mehr ganz so ins Gewicht gefallen. Ansonsten, muss ich sagen, finde ich, und das habe ich in Click and Rush auch oft gesagt bei uns, es gibt noch ein paar Charakter-Tests zum Schluss für Arsenal, vor allen Dingen in Manchester United, die, glaube ich, gegen ein so dominantes Team, Sea City im FA Cup-Finale, total hässlich sein können mit ihrer Art und Weise. Und das hat Arsenal bravourös gelöst. Sie haben teilweise in engen Spielen hinten raus noch den Sieg gemacht, eben gegen United zum Beispiel, mit einer der Momente der Saison wahrscheinlich, weil sie eben spät gewonnen haben und gezeigt haben, dass dieses Team legit ist. Deswegen würde ich nicht sagen, die haben es weggeschmissen. Das Problem ist eher, City hat nichts mehr weggeschmissen. Das ist das Problem, mal wieder. Die sind dermaßen professionell unterwegs, dass das eher der Stärke, City zuzurechnen ist, als irgendeine schwäche Arsenal ist. Weil die gab es de facto fast gar nicht in der Saison. Und schon gar nicht mehr ab 2024. Also wenn wir von der Phase sprechen, in der wir sagen können, da hätten sie vielleicht ein, zwei Siege mehr holen können, dann war das kurz vor Weihnachten, als sie zwar dominant gespielt haben, sogar noch dominanter als 2024, aber sie haben nicht so ganz effizient getroffen, wie sie es gehabt haben und waren nicht ganz so extrem elitär bei Standard-Situationen, sondern da haben sie ein paar weniger reingehauen. Und da haben sie ein paar Punkte liegen lassen, aber ganz ehrlich, ja, in jeder, nicht in jeder, aber in, sagen wir mal, ich weiß, ich kann jetzt nicht die Zahl nennen, aber vom Gefühl her, in den letzten zehn Jahren werden sie mit dieser Leistung achtmal Meister gewonnen. Es ist ja auch die punktetechnisch bessere Saison, als die Invincibles, das 24 geschafft haben. Das ist der Standard, in dem wir inzwischen unterwegs sind in der Liga.
Ja, das ist schon Wahnsinn. Und wo dann natürlich auch Manchester City der wesentliche Treiber ist, dem jagen alle hinterher. Und mit Manchester City ist eine Konstanz im Exzellenten in die Liga gekommen, die es vorher so nie gab und die vielleicht auch nicht das ist, was die Leute auf Dauer wirklich sehen wollen. Aber nun ist es eben einfach so, wie hat City das wieder geschafft? Ich weiß noch, dass Yogi war das, glaube ich. Der hat irgendwann im August oder September schon gesagt, na ja, City hat jetzt gerade eine Schwächephase, aber das Problem ist, die bräuchten sie im Frühjahr, weil im Frühjahr gewinnen sie ja immer alles. Und so war es ja jetzt dann auch. Es gab die eine Ausnahme, das Realspiel, das haben, denke ich, alle mitbekommen, wie das auch funktioniert hat. Und das ist halt einfach kryptonit, also real in der Champions League, gegen die verlieren jetzt letztlich alle, inklusive aller Bundesligisten. Also wie schafft das Pep Guardiola wieder und wieder und wieder, dass Manchester City nicht verliert in den wichtigen Phasen?
Ja, das ist echt erstaunlich. Und das ist noch mal im Vergleich zur letzten Saison, da war es ja auch schon so ähnlich. Es ist noch mal, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sagen soll, professioneller geworden wahrscheinlich. Also es ist inzwischen egaler, wie das aussieht bei City. Hauptsache, sie gewinnen es irgendwie. Und es ist nicht so, dass es hässlich wäre oder so, gar nicht. Sondern ich kann mich da schon dran erfreuen, dass man in so einer fast klinischen Sauberkeit die Spiele dann am Ende gewinnt. Aber trotzdem erstaunlich, dass mitunter, und das ist dann ein Unterschied, die Leistungen nicht so überzeugend waren. Also der 37. Spieltag, das ist total bescheuert gewesen in der Premier League-Saison, mal wieder in der Saison, dass der FA Cup die späten Runden dann die Liga so auseinanderzieht. Das heißt, das de facto 37. Spiel von City in der Saison war der 34. Spieltag und den gab es erst in der Woche hin zum Finale. Und gerade dieses Spiel, und das ist wahrscheinlich dann am Ende der sportliche Moment der Saison, gibt es in der 86. Minute die Szenen, in der Sonnen komplett alleine auf Stefano Tega zuläuft und der ist einfach im 1 gegen 1 unglaublich und löst das. Sonst sieht es anders aus für den letzten Spieltag. Und das war eine Leistung in der ersten Hälfte von City. Das hat Ante Posticocco einfach ziemlich clever gemacht, hat ihnen eine super Aufgabe gestellt, Zentrum zu gehalten, hat mit zwei, also ich habe immer gelesen, zwei Neuner, ich glaube es waren am Ende zwei Achter, die halt unterschiedlich in die Spitzen gelaufen sind. Und das hat City nicht gecheckt. Und zwar runde 50 Minuten lang nicht gecheckt. Und das alleine habe ich so noch nicht erlebt, dass in dieser Saison überdurchschnittlich viele Rezepte gefunden wurden gegen Manchester City. Und dann aber wiederum innerhalb des Spiels City ein Rezept findet, und das ist noch der große Unterschied zu Arsenal, wenn es nur ein Einzelspieler ist, der dann einfach das Spiel am Schopf packt und eine Aktion bringt, einen Steckpass durchspielt oder sei es Phil Foden, der immer gleiche Move, der einfach sich anbietet, so halbgeschlossene Spielstellung, ganz offen, ganz wie man es haben will, dann nimmt er den Ball in die Drehung mit und boom, dann ist er drin. Und das hat er ein paar Mal gemacht, so hat er es dann am Ende gegen West Ham entschieden, so ging es gegen Brentford, so hat er es gegen Manchester United gemacht. Also das war schon wichtiger als sonst, dass City die Einzelspiele auch dabei hatte. Also es war nicht so viel im Kollektiv hatte ich das Gefühl, es waren schon auch die Einzelleistungen, das muss man ihn wiederum zugute halten oder aber auch ins Minus rechnen, dass eben nicht alles totale Dominanz hatte, sondern wenn ein Team in dieser Saison die die meisten Sachen dominiert hat, dann war es ja eher sogar Arsenal. Was dann wiederum mich freudig stimmt für die kommende Saison, weil ich möchte schon noch mal sehen, dieses Duell. Arsenal hat nicht verloren gegen die großen Teams in der Saison, waren auch die Einzigen, die einen Sieg haben machen können. City hat Arsenal nicht gepackt in der Saison. Und das finde ich schon nicht unspannend, muss ich sagen, an der Gesamtkonzertsäule. Ich habe das, wenn ich jetzt so überlege, es ist gerade erst durch, aber ich freue mich dann schon auf 2024.
Bist du schon richtig heiß, können wir direkt die Vorschau aufnehmen. Sehr gut. Also das war das Meisterschaftsrennen, das zwischendurch ein Wettbewerb aus drei Teams war. Wir hatten es nicht gedacht, am Ende ist es dann City geworden. Das hätten wir vielleicht gedacht, aber es wurde ja alles garniert auch noch mit diesem FA Cup Finale. Also es war wirklich viel mit dabei in dieser Saison, mit allen Geschmacksrichtungen. Was ist denn vielleicht noch so die zweite große Geschichte dieser Saison? Also wohl wissend, dass wir jetzt nicht alles erzählen werden können.
Ja, aber die ist glaube ich klar, weil es sowohl sportpolitische Auswirkungen hat, als auch sportliche Auswirkungen und als auch eine der wahrscheinlich größten Rettungsaktionen in der Geschichte des englischen Fußballs dann zur Folge getragen hat. Es ist ein großes Thema geworden, die sogenannten Nachhaltigkeitsregelungen der Premier League und die Art und Weise, wie umgegangen worden ist damit, also sprich, wie sie kommuniziert worden sind, aber in allererster Linie mal das sie ausgeführt wurden. Denn das war ja fast unvorstellbar, dass dem so sein könnte. Und am Ende gab es zwei Teams, die unterschiedliche Punktabzüge bekommen haben zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten und in einem Fall ja sogar dreimal nachgebessert, was ein fälliger Wahnsinn ist, sodass ich schon gar nicht mehr weiß, am Ende wie viel es wirklich waren. Also Nottingham hat glaube ich minus 4 bekommen und bei Everton müssten es, ich hoffe, ich bin in Zahlen so mies, aber ich hoff, ich bodge das jetzt nicht. Minus 8 glaube ich sind es am Ende, fällt aber gar nicht mehr ins Gewicht, wie viel es bei Everton am Ende waren, weil sie sich schon weit, weit, weit vor Tore Schluss gerettet hatten. Und das dem so ist, halte ich für eine der größten Leistungen überhaupt. Es gibt diesen, ich glaube, das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt auch, aber ich liebe das so sehr. Es gibt den Film The Great Escape mit dem Hauptdarsteller James Garner. Und James Garner spielt beim FC Everton im Mittelfeld und ist einer so meiner Darlings, was so das Spielen betrifft, vor allen Dingen die langen Bälle betrifft. Und es war definitiv The Great Escape von John Deitch. Absolut chaotische Verhältnisse in dem ganzen Verein seit Jahren. Wir wussten es nicht bis zu der Saison. Jetzt haben wir es dann zumindest vermutet, dass das alles stimmt, dass sowohl hinter den Kulissen als auch finanziell einfach überhaupt gar nichts stimmt in dem Club. Die waren sportlich absoluter Müll und das ist aber vorbei. Das sieht zumindest, das ist jetzt nicht höchst ansehnlich, aber zumindest hat Deitch die komplett so gecoacht, dass die sogar richtung einstellig unterwegs gewesen wären. Und das halte ich für eine Monsterleistung ehrlich gesagt.
Und was würdest du sagen, waren jetzt dann in der Vergangenheit die wichtigsten Themen? Also wenn jetzt noch mal im Nachhinein Dinge rausgekommen sind, was bedeutet das, dass es kein gut organisierter Verein war? Wie hat sich das ausgedrückt?
Also es ging los, dass es einen Besitzer gab in Fahdmusch, oder gibt immer noch leider. Der Takeover sicher, das ist ja auch so eine Zeitgeschichte der Saison. Der Takeover hätte ja eigentlich im Oktober, im November schon durchgezogen werden sollen mit 777, die dann aber, können ja nicht offenbar, oder in dem Fall fehlte immer noch das ein oder andere. Moscheri hat als er kam, ganz schnell ganz viel Geld in die Hand genommen, ohne sich darum zu kümmern, dass irgendwas davon wieder reinkommt. Und das ist jetzt auf dem Spielermarkt, das einmal gewesen, aber auf der anderen Seite auch auf dem Trainermarkt. Da ging es einfach nur Namen, Namen, Namen und der Rest war wurscht. Und dann gab es zum Beispiel, also ich greife jetzt nur exemplarisch rein, weil es viel zu lang dauert, das alles zu erzählen. Da gab es exemplarisch die Woche, in der zum Beispiel Rafa Benitez entlassen wurde und die Geschichte mit Luca Dignier als Beispiel, dass Dignier dann verkauft worden ist. Und eine Woche später wird Rafa Benitez entlassen, der sich nachweislich mit dem gestritten hatte. Und dann hat man sozusagen einen Linksverteidiger, auf den man total gesetzt hat, einfach weggegeben, weil man den Trainer stärken wollte. Und dann ist der Trainer weg. Und im selben Atemzug wird Marcel Brandstang gekickt, der aber noch ein paar Wochen zuvor in den Vorstand gehoben worden ist. Und dann lag das alles ewig brach. Dann haben sich wieder die etwas Älteren, das sogenannte Bord, das ist auch so eine Tragik, dass Bill Kentright in diesem Jahr verstorben ist. Die haben sich dann wieder stärker eingemischt. Die sollen einen sehr traditionellen Ansatz gehabt haben. Das heißt, die wollten eher immer die Sam Allardyces haben und so was. Und David Moyes zurück und sich komplett lösen von dem, was Brands versucht hat, reinzubringen, was jetzt beim PSV ganz gut funktioniert. Und so gab es da hinter den Kulissen einfach so HSV-Gemängelagen. Jeder spricht, jeder spricht auch gerne öffentlich und steckt dann den Medien alles, was sie gerne haben wollten, führte dann ja dazu, dass in der letzten Saison fast zu bürgerkriegsartige Zustände da waren. So haben es die Kollegen aus Everton beschrieben, weil es teilweise so war, dass die mit Polizeischutz auch die Spieler vom Platz geleitet werden mussten, als auch eben Morddrohungen gegen Kendrite und Co. Das hat ja dann auch daran resultiert, dass sie Anthony Gordon verkauft haben, was nachweislich ein riesengroßer Fehler ist, weil er bei Newcastle volle Kanne funktioniert. Und das hat logischerweise, das was ich dir jetzt sage, hat er auch gewisse finanzielle Zwänge und dann auch einfach Nachwirkungen, dass sie einfach komplett falsch bilanziert hatten, dass sie einfach gedacht haben, ach, das können wir da hin. Der Stadionbau, der sich ewig gezogen hat, ist fast doppelt so teuer geworden, am Ende wie er geplant war. Auch das hat sich ja ewig gezogen. Da gibt es ja immer noch, dass Everton denkt, dass es nicht korrekterweise in diesen Rechnungskreislauf gelaufen ist, wird auch noch nachverhandelt. Also es ist im Übrigen auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es für die kommende Saison dann wieder weitere Punktabzüge gibt, weil es ist ja ein geschlossener Zeitraum, der untersucht worden ist. Also kurz an allen Ecken und Enden ist bei Everton, glaube ich, wirklich Chaos im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und das ist ja das, was die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln bestrafen. Und deswegen glaube ich, das allerletzte, was jetzt fehlt, das Bord des Altes weg, in dem Fall tragischerweise, weil einer verstorben ist, der mächtigste sozusagen. Das wünscht man ihm natürlich nicht. Aber was jetzt noch fehlt, damit glaube ich, Everton-Fans wieder eigenmaßen ruhig schlafen können, ist, dass Fahad Moschiri endlich abdankt. Und dann ist dieses leidige Thema vorbei. Der hat einfach auch keinen Bock mehr auf den Verein. Und dann glaube ich, kann man positiv in die Zukunft blicken. Da sind ja noch ein paar Spieler drin, die vielleicht dann, um den Punktabzug zu vermeiden, Geld einspielen können. Also, und andere vor allen Dingen, an die mir alle interessiert sein sollen. Da kann man viel, viel Geld mitmachen, glaube ich. Und dann bin ich zum ersten Mal seit Jahren, zumindest ist Gleichstimmung, aber eher Tendenz Richtung Positiv.
Und, also danke nochmal für diese Ausführung, weil die Anschlussfrage muss ja dann sein, wie hat es denn Jean Daish dann geschafft, eben da Ruhe reinzubringen und sportliche Ergebnisse zu liefern, bis hin zum ganz wichtigen Derby Sieg gegen Liverpool?
Also, der hat, wie immer, der geht sehr sachlich an die ganzen Dinge ran. Ich habe schon gefunden, dass die Transfers, die er im Sommer gemacht hat, und das ist er dann nachweislich eher, weil er ist der mächtigste Mann in dem Verein und der einzige, der irgendwas zu melden hat, er hat gecheckt, okay, was brauche ich? Eine gewisse Körperlichkeit. Ich gehe das Ganze einfach an über Low Block sozusagen. Also, er geht aggressiv auf den Abstoß drauf und sobald sie da nichts bekommen, dann ziehen sie sich zurück und verfallen in den Low Block. Und das hat der Mannschaft wahnsinnig gut getan. Brandthwaite ist de facto kein Neuzugang gewesen, aber tut nach seiner Laie dem Ganzen sehr, sehr gut. Er kam zurück und ist einfach ein fertigerer Spieler gewesen. Das war zum einen mal so, dann vor allen Dingen in dem Sturm eine Lösung gefunden, um den immer verletzten Dominik Herbert Lewin fürs Erste zu ersetzen. Und dann, als er wieder da war, konnte der einigermaßen gesund bleiben zum ersten Mal. Auch das habe ich so nicht gesehen. Und dann hat er dem Ganzen einfach ein total klares Spielsystem verordnet. Da hieß es eben Low Block, du musst nicht zwingend viel Ballbesitz haben. Wir schlagen, sobald es geht, lang. Deswegen auch nicht unwichtig, dass sie die Stürmertypen hatten, die sie ausgewählt haben, eben in Herbert Lewin, den ich nach wie vor für, wenn er gesund ist, einen richtig starken Spieler halte. Für Beto, der teilweise das sehr, sehr gut gemacht hat, dann auch eine Phase jetzt gerade im Mr. April wahrscheinlich gewesen sein gehabt hat, wenn es auch nur drei, vier Spiele waren, in denen der unglaublich wichtig war. Offball zum Beispiel und das ist ein vergleichsweise einfaches Konzept gewesen, ist aber auch cool geblieben, auch das muss man sagen. Es gab die Phase ab Dezember, da haben sie zwei Monate fast alles verloren. Das war ja eines der besten Spiele der ganzen Saison in diesem PSA-Dubbie. Er wird gegen Nottingham, die beiden mit Punktabzügen. Ist das so kulminiert, dass man dachte, wenn er das nicht gewinnt, dann fliegt er vielleicht sogar. Wann immer sie gebraucht wurden in der Saison, waren sie da. Sie haben wirklich eine gute Leistung gezeigt. Sie waren eine präsente Leistung, die sie jeweils gezeigt haben. Sie waren immer auf den Gegner gut eingestellt. Sie waren fast ausschließlich körperlich überlegen. Das sorgt dann dafür, dass sie die Stürme gemeistert haben. Hätten sie eine etwas bessere Chancenverwertung gehabt, die bodenlos die schlechteste der ganzen Liga, dann wären sie sogar noch besser gewesen. Also das Spiel Everton hätte sogar noch mehr hergegeben, als am Ende wirklich da war. Deswegen möchte ich einfach fast ein doppeltes Plus hinter die Saison machen. Das ist jetzt alles, was mir gerade so einfällt. Ich hoffe, dass es nicht zu wirr ist. Aber ich glaube, das zeichnet die Saison ganz gut nochmal wieder mit dieser einen Delle, die sie hatten.
Absolut. Dann bleiben noch die Saison-Awards. Das heißt MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment der Saison. Weil ich nämlich auch den Eindruck habe, ich glaube, auf ein ganz großes Thema werden wir im Zuge dieser Awards noch zu sprechen kommen. Ansonsten werde ich dich mit einer Nachfrage dazu völlig aus dem Nichts treffen. Also lass mal mit dem MVP beginnen. Wer war für dich der MVP dieser Saison?
Ich habe logischerweise ein bisschen überlegt, wie ich das mache. Und in dieser Saison gab es nicht so sehr den einen Spieler, der das gemacht hätte. Also wo man jetzt klar sagen konnte, das war der Spieler der Saison. Phil Foden, das ist ja ganz offiziell geworden. Und ich kann das auch nachvollziehen, weil der in entscheidenden Situationen da war, dass er es geworden ist. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, gibt es denn irgendwo irgendwas anderes, also irgendjemanden, den man nennen könnte, der auf einer Position, sei es jetzt als Funktionär oder als Trainer oder so irgendwas gemacht hat. Und auch da komme ich aber nicht zu einem richtigen Ergebnis, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, okay, das war für mich absolut klar derjenige. Man könnte Ainz Poste Kogelon nehmen, weil der die Stimmung deutlich zum Positiven verändert hatte bei Tottenham, aber zum Schluss ist das krass eingekracht. Und ich habe sogar jetzt gehört, dass der zur Disposition stehen soll, weil es einen heftigeren Krach gibt, als das zunächst angenommen wurde. Auch wenn mir dann wiederum, das weiß ich aus intern, dass man schon sehr stark in Richtung Ainz Ball weiterhin plant und auch alle Scouts und so weiter. Dazu angehalten sind, dass sie weiterhin für Ainz verpflichten. Aber ja, das ist ein Fall gewesen. Dann könnte man, und auf den läuft es wahrscheinlich am Ende hinaus, wahrscheinlich mit Unai Emery gehen. Weil Platz 4 in dieser Liga, Champions-League-Qualifikation, die großen beiden nicht nur geschlagen, sondern vorgeführt, jeweils taktisch gesehen in den Spielen. Und zwei Vertragsverlängerungen innerhalb einer Saison, glaube ich, gab es so auch noch nicht, mit immer noch steigender Macht. Auch im Übrigen völlig zu Recht für Unai Emery. Deswegen würde ich wahrscheinlich am Ende den nennen. Foden kriegt so ein Bleistiftsternchen daneben, weil er als Spieler der Saison, glaube ich, schon auch zu nennen ist. Das ist schon in Ordnung für mich. Aber wenn ich einen nennen müsste, der diese Saison als Person alles überragt hatte, dann muss das, glaube ich, Unai Emery sein.
Und habe ich das richtig verstanden? Unai Emery hat gleich zweimal seinen Vertrag verlängert während dieser Saison.
Warum? Weil die, glaube ich, sicherstellen wollen, dass der auf gar keinen Fall jemals abhaut von Essen Willer. Also die sind hoch, hoch glücklich mit dem. Der durfte sich seinen kompletten Staff zusammenstellen, seinen Kumpelsportdirektor und so weiter. Also all die Dinge, die ihm oftmals verwehrt worden sind, in anderen Stellen, vor allen Dingen bei Arsenal nachweislich, weil die ja gesagt haben, wir wollen jetzt nicht die Emerisierung Arsenals haben, sondern wir möchten schon, dass der Club bleibt. Du bist hier nur der Manager und Aston Villa ist ganz klar unter Emery's Club. Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Manager in England, der so mächtig ist wie Emery inzwischen. Rein technisch gesehen war die zweite Vertragsverlängerung nach Saisonende. Ich glaube, zwei Tage danach oder einen Tag danach gab es dann die nächste Aufbesserung des Gehalts. Und ich tippe mal, vor allen Dingen sind wahrscheinlich die Felder da nochmal etwas spezifiziert worden. Also sprich Machtgewinn von Emery. Es gab ja die angebliche Anfrage von Bayern, die es meiner Meinung nach nicht gegeben hat. Und ich habe auch nicht gehört, dass es die gegeben hat. Sondern es war wirklich ein Grundinteresse, dass man mal überlegt hat, könnten wir den Anfragen und dann ist er ja, glaube ich, am selben Abend noch gefragt worden, ob er sich das vorstellen könnte und hat gesagt, ne kann er nicht, was auch einfach so war. Aber ein richtiges Interesse gab es da nicht. Aber ich meine, die ersten Wille ist nicht doof. Die wissen ganz genau, wo immer jetzt ein Trainer irgendwo entlassen wird, wird man sich mit Una Emery beschäftigen und dem möchte man gleich mal zuvorkommen, indem man ihm sagt, was auch immer du denkst, an die Wand hängen zu müssen, go for it.
Okay, sehr gut. Siehst du, die zweite hatte ich nämlich gar nicht mitbekommen, die zweite Vertragsverlängerung. Wer ist denn dann dein Anzang-Hero dieser Saison?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr schwierig. Auf der ersten Ebene, auf der zweiten glaube ich nicht so schwierig. Ich nehme Andoni Iirola. Ich bleibe jetzt mal bei den Trainern einfach, weil das auch so eine Geschichte ist, die erzählt werden muss in dieser Saison. Die haben die ersten Spiele allesamt verloren. Der war schon vor der Länderspielpause im Oktober, also vor der letzten in 2023, eigentlich schon weg. Wenn er das Spiel nicht gewonnen hätte, dann wäre es auch passiert. Das ist auch die Information, die ich hatte von den sehr, sehr, in dem Fall Kollegen, sehr, sehr gut gebrieften Kollegen. Und dann gab es dieses Spiel gegen Newcastle, als Newcastle mit Aach und Krach noch eine Truppe zusammenbekommen hat auf dem Platz, weil die die Verletzungsgebeutelten überhaupt in der Saison. Und dieses Spiel hat Bournemouth gewonnen. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt konntest du fast peu à peu feststellen, ach, guck mal, da wird aus einer passiven Truppe eine Pressing-Truppe. Es hat offensichtlich ein wenig gedauert, ehe sie klarkommen. Junge Spieler, die nicht verstanden haben oder es einfach nicht so durchführen konnten, wie Iraola das wollte. Und das eine Erfolgserlebnis, so scheint es jetzt im Nachhinein, am Ende weiß man, war Glasner ja auch so ähnlich, am Ende weiß man einfach, wenn ein Trainer eine Idee hat, wird es auch ein bisschen dauern, bis er die implementieren kann. Und offensichtlich arbeiten die Tag für Tag daran. Und es passiert nicht einfach über Nacht. Und so ist es gewesen, dass man dann peu a peu feststellen konnte, ach, okay, Iraolas Idee wirkt, bis sie zum Schluss sogar eins der unterhaltsamsten Teams gewesen sind, eine Streak hingelegt haben von, auch da müsste ich jetzt lügen, ich glaube nur zwei Niederlagen in 13 oder 14 spielen, und ich glaube, dass das, ich habe zu Beginn der Saison gesagt, eins der interessantesten Projekte, weil da mit Foley einer dahintersteht, der amerikanisch große Töne spuckt und die bleiben immer nebulös, weil man nie genau weiß, was er damit meint, aber bis dato hat er mit allem Wort gehalten, es ist immer Schritt für Schritt für Schritt dazugekommen und jetzt haben sie, glaube ich, den Trainer, der diese Vision hat, die glaube ich sehr wichtig ist für den Club, Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass sie in die Runde kommt und sie offensichtlich auch auf den Platz transferiert bekommt. Und das gemischt mit sehr, sehr jungen, interessanten Spielern und weiterhin der Idee, als auch jetzt so, dass es beritzeln muss für Spieler, dass sie vielleicht dahingehen, lässt mich auch wieder positiv in die Zukunft blicken. Ich hab das Gefühl, da war sogar noch ein bisschen mehr drin am Ende in der Tabelle. Platz 9 wäre möglich gewesen, wenn die aber so in der Schlagzahl weitermachen, wie jetzt in der Rückrunde zumindest. Dann sind sie nächstes Jahr sogar ein Fringe-Contender für Europa, also wenigstens die Conference League. Deswegen würde ich sagen, es ist über jeden gesprochen worden, Trainer, über so viele Spieler, wie Colt Palmer oder so, die einen großen Schritt gemacht haben in der Saison. Ich hatte Johann Wissar noch mal auf dem Schirm, den ich als einen der Most Improved-Player hatte bei Brentford in der Zeit, als Toni und Bumeaux weg waren. Ohne den wären sie wahrscheinlich sicher abgestiegen. So waren sie eh auch in der Nähe, muss man ehrlicherweise sagen. Man hätte Ross Barkley nennen können, er ist alle gesungen worden. Ich glaube, bei Iraula, das ging fast unter am Ende. Auch wenn es dann so rund um den 35., 36. schon mal das eine oder andere Stück gegeben hat von, er hat den Turnaround geschafft und so. Aber so knapp, wie es war, und so war es wohl wirklich hin zu, jetzt denken sie, sie haben ihn gefunden, das finde ich erstaunlich und deshalb soll der auch mal hier vorkommen. Ich glaube, Bournemouth war wahrscheinlich auch das einzige Team, das sich nur einmal thematisiert hatte bei dir im Verlaufe der Saison. Insofern wäre es ja auch sinnvoll.
Sehr, sehr schön. Und dann brauchen wir noch den Moment der Saison. Ich habe das Gefühl, schon eine Richtung zu kennen, in die es gehen könnte.
Du meinst den Abschied von David Moisner.
Genau, die emotionalen Szenen, wie er sein letztes Fistpump gemacht hat.
Also wir haben den Moment des Jahres bei uns im Podcast auch gekürt. Für mich war der Ortega gegen Sonnen fast sogar größer, weil ich wahrscheinlich aber darauf vorbereitet war für den Rest der Menschheit. Und das kann man auch nachvollziehen, der Abschied Jürgen Klops in Liverpool oder aber, ich glaube, das steht nicht so weit daneben, die Nachricht, dass er gehen würde. Die war vielleicht sogar noch, man konnte ja ein halbes Jahr lang sich darauf vorbereiten, in Anführungszeichen. Ich fand die Abschlusszeremonie jetzt nicht so besonders, muss ich sagen. Ich habe die aber auch nur im Fernsehen geguckt, während ich mich auf die Meisterschaftsfeier Citys vorbereitet habe, die ich dann noch zu kommentieren hatte. Das heißt vielleicht liegt es auch daran, aber ich habe gedacht, vielleicht, ich bin ja auch ein bisschen sensibler geworden in den letzten Jahren, vielleicht muss ich dann sogar wirklich irgendwie weinen, wenn der was Schönes sagt oder so, weil ergreifende Momente ergreifen mich jetzt mitunter schon auch, aber null.
Nicht mal bei seiner Rede, seine Rede fand ich schon.
Nee, gar nicht. Also wirklich gar nicht. Aber wie gesagt, das mag vielleicht am Set-up liegen, dass ich halt professionell war an dem Punkt, dass es in mir wenig gemacht hat. Aber ich hatte auch nie den Moment, also gab ja Kollegen, die dann davon erzählt haben, und ich habe ja die alles mit begleitet und deswegen ist das für mich so. Und ich weiß auch noch damals, als ich die, da war ich noch Praktikant, da habe ich die Neuigkeit, dass Brenton Rogers entlassen wird und das Club, der Favorit ist, an den CVD ganz aufgeregt weitergegeben und der hat mich nur angeguckt und sagt so, ja, cool, schön für dich. Weil der halt auch im Moment jetzt nicht so, Alter, da ist gerade Brenton Rogers entlassen worden. Er sagt so, ja, setz dich wieder hin, wir machen eine Meldung, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so weltbewegend. Und was dann natürlich passiert ist im Nachhinein war dann schon sehr weltbewegend, aber die Rede als solche war für mich, wahrscheinlich war es eher die Nachricht tatsächlich, weil die hat mich völlig kalt erwischt, hab ich null mit gerechnet. Und das, so kumuliert war wahrscheinlich, waren schon die Momente der Saison und das sind ja auch welche. Mein Ortega gegen Sonnen, okay, gut, ist ein What-If, aber da wird man noch in Jahren drauf schauen, vielleicht sogar wieder in ein paar Monaten. Also Anislot hat ein schwieriges Erbe anzutreten. Kann sogar sein, dass man das dann nochmal rausholen wird, wenn es nicht so läuft. Also der wird jetzt erstmal über Enfield schweben. Und deswegen, ja, ist es logisch, das ist, glaube ich, der Moment des letzten Jahrzehnts wahrscheinlich für alle, die es mit Liverpool halten. Und vielleicht sogar minus der Ablöse von Sir Alex Ferguson, weil in die Richtung geht es ja schon fast, ist das der größte Moment so auf einer Gesamtebene.
Ich versuche mal, all meine 1000 Fragen, weil man kann natürlich über Jürgen Klopp ganze Podcasts füllen und es wird ja auch eigene Podcasts nur dazu geben und man kann bei euch nachhören und es gibt noch andere Formate. Ich versuche es mal auf zwei Fragen zu reduzieren. Was, glaubst du, hat er nach Liverpool gebracht und für den FC Liverpool bedeutet?
Also das Allerwichtigste, neben ein paar Titeln, die da waren, gerade der Premier League-Titel, den darf man glaube ich nicht unterschätzen für Liverpool, aber vor allen Dingen hat er den Verein revitalisiert. Also er hat sie wieder glauben lassen, dass alles möglich ist und nicht schon vorher reingehen lassen, naja, okay, ist eh vorbei. Das ist glaube ich das Allerwichtigste der Kulturwandel, den er geschaffen hat. Das positive Denken zurück an Liverpool und dann unter der Fanway Sports Group, dass er nicht allein für verantwortlich, aber hauptverantwortlich sie zurück in die Weltspitze gehoben. Also Topspieler möchten gerne wieder zu Liverpool und das tun sie ja nicht nur, weil es gutes Geld gibt oder weil es da so schön wäre, sondern weil sie denken, die Kultur dieses Vereins ist genau die Richtige, um erfolgreich zu sein. Das ist eine Endstation geworden. Vorher war es ja oft eine Vorstation für die Endstation. Das ist glaube ich das allergrößte Vermächtnis. Da muss man glaube ich auch nicht so viel drüber erzählen, sondern da sind sich glaube ich auch alle einig drüber.
Und was glaubst du bedeutet es, dass das mit Jürgen Klopp ein Deutscher geschafft hat in der Premier League? Ich bin jetzt eigentlich nicht so derjenige, der in Nationalitäten denkt, aber Henrik hat ein ganzes Buch über die Rivalität zwischen Deutschland und England geschrieben, also die sportliche Rivalität.
Ja, also das ist ja kein Geheimnis. Vor allen Dingen schauen die Champions League. Generell war das bei Spielern schon seit Jahren der Fall. Also das ging so 2015 circa los, vor allen Dingen von Stuart Webber, der irgendwann mal gecheckt hat als Sportdirektor, der deutsche Markt ist kein uninteressanter. Da gibt es Spieler, die sind genauso gut oder gleich gut wie die Engländer, sind aber um die Hälfte günstiger, was Gehalt betrifft und vor allem die hinablösen. Und irgendwann hat er auch mal gesagt, es gibt da diesen Gegenpressing-Ansatz aus Deutschland, den es in England zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht so gab. Der kam entweder von der spanischen Färbung her. Auch da hat man sich schon anleihen genommen, nimmt man ja weiterhin, also die Liga ist spanischer denn je, wenn man sich die Übungsleiter anguckt, auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite aber auch der deutsche Ansatz. Schau mal jetzt, Hall City nimmt Tim Walther. Bis vor kurzem war noch David Wagner bei Neusch. Dann war oder ist Daniel Fakl bei Leeds noch unterwegs. Danny Röhl, der dieses unglaubliche Wunder mit Sheffield Wednesday geschafft hat. Das geht gar nicht, dass der drin bleibt. Auch in der 3. Liga, weiß ich von 4, 5, 6 deutschen Trainern, die werden immer wieder in Erwägung gezogen. Auch von Agenturen rangebracht aufgrund von Zahlen einfach nur. Also ganz billig datenbasierten Auswertungen der bisherigen Stationen. Und das Gleiche ist selbstverständlich auch in der 1. Liga passiert. Oliver Glasner, die Engländer machen ja keinen Unterschied zwischen Deutschen und Österreichern. Das ist das Lustige. Deswegen ist Oliver Glasner deutscher für die. Fertig. Und auch den haben sie genommen. Oliver Glasner hat diese Liga im Sturm erobert. Völlig zurecht im Übrigen, im Sturm erobert. Und das wird zur Folge haben, dass weitere Trainer für England in Erwägung gezogen werden. Und das ging aber vor allen Dingen im Mainstream los mit Jürgen Klopp und dieser Art und Weise, die er gebracht hat. Also das ist für das Übungslehrertum Deutschlands ist das sehr, sehr positiv gewesen, diese Art und Weise, wie er gewirkt hat.
Wird man wahrscheinlich auch erst mit einigen Jahren Abstand erkennen können. Das Buch von Hendrik ist übrigens We Call it a Klassiker, die Engländer der Fußball und wir. Und wer die Ligatur nur ein bisschen verfolgt, der weiß natürlich, das muss man durchlesen und man muss click and rush hören. Und deswegen war ich auch sehr froh, Uli, dass du jetzt hier spontan noch die Zeit hattest. Danke dir, es war eine unheimlich interessante Saison. Mit der EM steht uns vielleicht auch ein nicht so unspannendes Turnier jetzt bevor. Ich bin sehr gespannt, welche Geschichten da noch geschrieben werden. Danke dir, stellvertretend für alle Premier League Experten, die hier in der Ligatur zu Gast waren. Danke Uli für deine Zeit.
War eine schöne Saison. Ich habe viel gelernt auch bei dir über die anderen Ligen auch, die ich ja sonst nur so teilweise begleite.
Absolut. Und wir haben uns hier auch durch den Delay durchgekämpft, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wenn es manchmal so ein bisschen zeitverzögert kam, dann lag es daran. Vor allem im Video wird man es sehen. Also im Audio kriege ich das hingeschnitten. Video wird man sehen, dass ihr wisst ja gar nicht, wo sich der Uli heute schon wieder durchkämpfen musste, damit er hier überhaupt zur Sendung erscheinen könnte. Also danke dir, lieber Uli. Und danke auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Unterstützung. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei D. Wegerle, bei Mattes, bei Christopher Woitus, bei Andy C., bei Tim Schnicks, bei Matthias und bei Jan auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr auch sehr gerne noch Merchandise kaufen. Außerdem abonniert unbedingt den Rasenfunk Nationalteams Feed, denn da wird es alles geben zur EM der Männer in diesem Sommer. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.